[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravis de vous retrouver
pour cette nouvelle séance de questions
d'actualité au sénat les sénateurs cette
semaine encore vont consacrer
l'intégralité de la séance à des
questions sur l'épidémie de covin 19 ils
vont interroger le gouvernement sur sa
gestion de la crise mais aussi bien sûr
sur l'oder confinement et sur le plan
prévu à partir du 11 mai et sur lequel
d'ailleurs le parlement travaille toute
cette semaine la séance commence dans
quelques minutes à 15 heures dans des
conditions qui respectent les consignes
sanitaires à mes côtés le sénateur l'est
républicain mathieu darnaud bonjour
sénateurs l air de l'ardèche
vous allez interroger le gouvernement
tout à l'heure avec une question sur les
élus l'école cette question de la
responsabilité des élus et bien elle
occupe énormément le sénat depuis le
début de cette semaine quels sont vos
craintes
si l'on ne touche pas à la loi fauchon
pour le déconfinement on voit bien
aujourd'hui que c'est une question qui
est particulièrement anxiogène que ce
soit pour les parents d'élèves que ce
soit pour les directeurs d'école les
enseignants mais aussi pour les mères
qui porte une lourde responsabilité dans
tant dans l'organisation de ses rentrées
que j'allais dire dans les moyens qu'ils
doivent mettre en oeuvre et qu'ils n'ont
pour certains pas considérons que les
communes notamment dans des territoires
ruraux mais aussi dans des grandes
villes comme paris et j'ajouterais des
moyens financiers parce que je veux
rappeler quand même que l'état a demandé
aux communes aux intercommunalités de
mettre en place des programmes
périscolaire et que tout ça pose des
questions autant en matière de
responsabilité que de moyens c'est ce
que nous essaierons d'éclaircir au
travers de la question du jour c'est ce
que nous avons essayé de pointé du doigt
en interpellant à plusieurs reprises le
gouvernement voilà et d'intégrer au
projet de loi de prorogation sur l'état
d'urgence sanitaire est ce que vous
comprenez le débat qui est en train de
monter sur ce sujet avec le fait que
cela choque certains qui estiment que
les élus finalement essaye de se couvrir
dans cette période non parce que on ôte
pas la responsabilité
des élus pas plus d'ailleurs que ceux
des directeurs d'école ou des chefs
d'entreprise en revanche nous sommes
dans une période tout à fait singulière
on demande une agilité extrême aux élus
d'appliquer des protocoles considérable
particulièrement lourd en des temps
records avec un manque de moyens évident
et je crois qu'il faut que l'état
accompagne notamment dans la
responsabilité et dans la mise en place
par c'est par ces élus par ses
directeurs d'école ses rentrées
scolaires dont je crois qu'on a essayé
d'avoir un texte équilibré mais qui
entend les préoccupations majeures des
élus est-ce que cela n'est pas un petit
peu trop large parce que le texte
englobe en plus des élus les entreprises
les fonctionnaires ce que c'est un point
qu'il peut bouger notamment commission
mixte non tout simplement parce que ce
sont les acteurs du déconfinement et que
au contraire on cible véritablement
celles et ceux qui vont avoir à assurer
ce déconfinement de façon très concret
très pragmatique
donc on n'est vraiment pas dans une
démarche où on chercherait à exonérer
quelques responsabilités quelques actes
qui serait malveillants et qui seraient
commis on est vraiment dont
l'accompagnement et dans la volonté de
ne pas faire en sorte que ses élus ses
directeurs et la peur au ventre le 11
mai comment jugez-vous à la position du
gouvernement qui a cherché donc à
supprimer cette mesure du projet de loi
précisons qu'une bonne partie des élus
arm et notamment tous au sénat sont pour
ce type de disque je la juge totalement
regrettable parce qu'on voit bien avec
cette unanimité dans l'hémicycle ici au
sénat unanimité qui est le reflet en
fait des aspirations de ce qu'on peut
entendre sur les territoires qu'il y a
vraiment lieu à agir en la matière et
que la position du gouvernement autant
sur la forme que sur le fond et est
dommageable parce que le gouvernement
devrait plutôt chercher à entendre et à
rassurer par des dispositions comme
celle que nous avons vécue donc nous
avons voté pardon donc c'est vraiment
quelque chose d'important pour nous eh
bien merci beaucoup m d'actions d'avoir
répondu à mes questions va prendre votre
place maintenant et bien la sénatrice us
et françoise gatel vous aussi vous allez
vous intéresser à cette question et d'un
des élus cette question des
collectivités mais d'abord vous
assistiez ce matin à l'audition de jean
castex le corps de l'international de la
stratégie
de déconfinement est-ce que vous en êtes
sortis rassurés tout simplement
en tout cas moi j'ai apprécié vous vous
rapprochez un tout petit peu de votre
micro
j'ai apprécié son propos qui étaient
très clair et très raisonnable il a bien
dit que le 11 mai était un démarrage de
déconfinement et qu'on allait
expérimenté si je puis dire des
conditions de déconfinement en
souhaitant qu'elles soient le plus
efficaces possible pour que ce qu'on se
déconfinement puis 7,6 non définitive
mais s'accentuer mais là notamment
expliqué que le plan de déconfinement
comprend un plan de reconfirmer on
comprend bien qu'il ya des risques à
ceux des confinement pour vous serrez ce
que sont-ils proportionnée sont ils bien
compris aujourd'hui il y à des risques
si jamais les dispositions sanitaires
n'étaient pas respectées donc c'est une
responsabilité collective mais surtout
il a mis en avant une réponse à une
suggestion qui largement formulées par
la commission des lois et la délégation
collectivités c'est un pilotage efficace
dans les territoires de la crise
aujourd'hui on constate qu'il ya des
pilotages parfois un bicéphale ya d'une
part le préfet qui est très engagée
auprès de tous les acteurs et les
préfets sont plutôt excellent et à côté
nous avons des solistes que peuvent être
les agences régionales de santé les
recteurs les finances publiques et qu'en
période de crise un commandement à
plusieurs têtes ça ne peut pas
fonctionner et qu'il faut donc une sorte
de task force autour du préfet qui
aurait à motoriser la délégation sur les
services déconcentrés parce que les
solutions sont là donc c'est vraiment
une demande que nous formulons parce que
c'est la réponse à une situation de
crise
françoise gatel vous aviez voté pour le
plan de re confirmé lundi cette
déclaration du gouvernement qui
d'ailleurs est bien a été finalement
rejetée par le sénat
qu'avez-vous pensez vous de cette
position du sénat comment est-ce que
vous l'interprétez alors moi je
comprends la position à titre personnel
j'ai voté j'ai voté favorablement parce
que je pense qu'il faut que nous
entamions le déconfinement d'une manière
raisonnable le premier ministre m'a
semblé très clair
mais aussi très prudent et qu'en même
temps je pense que dans cette période où
nous pouvons les uns et les autres
formuler des critiques
il est important de montrer qu'il ya une
sorte de responsabilité nationale est en
tout cas de ne pas ouvrir la voie à des
bisbilles politiques
maintenant je sais le cas avec ce vote
non non mais la presse se saisit la
presse se saisit toujours de choses de
cette nature et l'amplifient donc moi je
vous comprends que ça puisse apparaître
comme un camouflet pour le gouvernement
que ce gars en tout cas c'est un
désaccord voilà s'est exprimé comme ça
et moi je les bien entendu ceci dit on a
vu comment le sénat à travailler de
manière très responsable sur le texte de
loi qui est arrivé en début de semaine
sur la prolongation de l'urgence
sanitaire avec des suggestions dans un
esprit responsable donc en quelque sorte
mon ouïe est un oui pas de bienveillance
mais c'est parce que je pense qu'il faut
qu'on est là et qu'on affirme les choses
et qu'en même temps il reste très
vigilant et très exigeant c'est pourquoi
je pense que nous avons des exigences à
formuler dans la gestion crise au plus
près des territoires
eh bien merci beaucoup françoise gatel à
une approbation mais une approbation
vigilante
maintenant on va prendre votre place le
président socialiste de la commission
des finances vincent eblé
vincent eblé vous aussi vous allez poser
une question de questions sur le
décompte finement votre groupe ah je le
rappelle voter d'ailleurs contre le plan
qui a été présenté par le gouvernement
lundi quelles sont pour vous et bien les
difficultés suscitées par ce plan il ya
plus de questions que de réponses donc
effectivement c'est assez compliqué
beaucoup de contradictions on le voit
bien
et surtout nous sommes préoccupés par la
question de la démocratie parlementaire
et ma question va aussi porter sur cette
question est ce que finalement dans
cette période particulière on doit
mettre la démocratie entre parenthèses
est-ce qu'elle aussi elle doit être
confiné
ou bien est-ce que le fonctionnement
parlementaire doit gérer trouver à
s'exprimer avec une majorité et une
opposition des confrontations de points
de vue on a vu un chef de la majorité
parlementaire
lrm
parler d' irresponsabilité à l'écart du
vote libre des parlementaires de la
haute assemblée cela nous préoccupe et
nous nous pensons que j'irai pour
assurer la cohésion du pays autour des
enjeux du déconfinement et de la lutte
contre le coc vie de 19
il convient de respecter la position des
uns et des autres et de laisser j'irai
la libre expression faire vivre la
démocratie parlementaire
vous jugez que ça a été le cas que la
démocratie parlementaire a été mis sous
cloche
pourquoi vous avez quand même tout de
même pu poursuivre un certain nombre
d'auditions on voit les textes on voit
ce travail de contrôle avec les
questions d'actualité au gouvernement
le travail parlementaire n'est pas du
tout en cause effectivement il agirait
pu se développer avec j'irai beaucoup de
de deux réunions et de séquences de
toute nature
mais c'est le discours qui
l'accompagnent et c'est aussi ce recours
assez systématique l'ordonance alors
pour aller vite au début de la crise que
le gouvernement ait souhaité être
habilitée à prendre les décisions sans
débat parlementaire par la voie
d'ordonnancés on peut l'entendre mais
que l'on poursuive avec cette
méthodologie dans de très nombreux
segments de l'action publique
ça commence à poser aujourd'hui un
véritable problème et nous nous
souhaitons que le parlement reste au
coeur de la décision relative à l'action
publique
un mot pour conclure sur et bien les
prises de parole au sein de l'exécutif a
notamment le fait que voir philippe
avait parlé de risque d'écroulement
d'écroulement économique s'il n'y avait
pas de confinement des mots qu emmanuel
macron a refusé d'employer ce que vous y
voyez vous des voix discordantes
aujourd'hui au sein de l'exécutif
oui bien sûr on les entend comme tous
les français peuvent les observer une
certaine cacophonie des prises de parole
y compris qui s'exprime dans le même
temps
le chef du gouvernement le chef de
l'état qui parlent en même temps que
l'autre je pense qu'un minimum de
coordination ne nuirait pas j'irai à la
qualité du débat public et de
l'explication à l'égard de nos
concitoyens de cette dernière question
l'institut montaigne qui propose de
supprimer des congés pour relancer
l'économie plus globalement faut-il
relancer le débat et bien sûr la durée
du travail
non je ne suis pas sur cette ligne là je
pense que notre économie doit d'abord
repartir sur des bases qui sont celles
gérées de notre droit du travail et que
ce n'est pas en me remettant en cause
les règles du droit du travail qu' on va
dynamiser l'économie
eh bien merci beaucoup vincent eblé
d'avoir répondu à mes questions je vous
laisser rejoindre l'hémicycle ou des
buts et bien cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement la cloche
vient de sonner direction l'hémicycle le
compte-rendu analytique de la précédente
séance a été distribué nous n'avons pas
reçu à cet instant d'observation il y en
a t'il en séance
l'envoi point il est donc adoptée sur
les réserves d'usagé sur premier
ministre madame et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues notre
religion rappelle les questions
d'actualité au gouvernement sous le
format adapté que nous avons défini
notre saison se déroule dans les
conditions de respect des règles
sanitaires et je vous rappelle que les
conditions d'entrée et sortie appel de
la part de chacun maîtriser leurs
pulsions et à se diriger pour les
sénateurs verts le couloir périphériques
et au monde du gouvernement de procéder
par le devant donc la parole est neutre
collègue joël guerriau pour le groupe
les ja dépendant le lait la parole merci
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre la liberté est la règle
les restrictions de police l'exception
par ces mots en 1917 le commissaire du
gouvernement corneille rappelait que
notre démocratie est guidé depuis la
révolution par le principe de liberté
bien entendu pour que cette liberté
s'exerce dans le respect de chacun elle
doit être encadrée par la loi
à cet égard la pandémie que nous
traversons oblige à définir de nouvelles
règles
il s'agit de mesures barrières à ce
titre il est peu compréhensible que les
policiers ne bénéficient pas
d'équipements de protection pour les
contrôler
d'ailleurs l'éloignement des individus
les uns des autres en limitant la
liberté d'aller et venir ne peut être
que transitoire
les français ont bien compris cette
nécessité et ont très majoritairement
fait preuve de cynisme de civisme
il faut garder à l'esprit que l'objectif
de ces règles est de garantir la liberté
et la sécurité de chacun avec le
déconfinement des interrogations
demeurent pour plusieurs situations au
delà de 100 km des étudiants finissent
leur année et vont souhaiter entrer chez
leurs parents des personnes âgées sont
isolées depuis trop longtemps et ont
besoin d'être soutenus par leurs proches
ces quelques exemples ne sont pas
exhaustifs mais rappelle que la vie
familiale des français n'est pas une
option
il ne faudrait pas sacrifier la liberté
de tous par crainte de
l'irresponsabilité de quelques uns
pouvez-vous lui dire monsieur le
ministre ce que recouvre le motif
familial impérieux qui permet de se
déplacer et si l'appréciation de ce
motif bénéficiera de la souplesse
nécessaires merci pour vous répondre la
parole et secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre l'intérieur monsieur rémunère
la parole monsieur le président mesdames
et messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur vous avez sous peine
d'interroger très clairement sur un
certain nombre de règles qui vont
s'appliquer à partir du 11 mai je
voudrais simplement rappeler vous l'avez
fait que jusqu'au 11 mai depuis le mois
de mars nous avons effectivement eu des
règles plus restrictives mais qui
10 et à éviter donc la propagation du
virus et que ces règles elles ont été
très majoritairement accepté et respecté
par nos concitoyens et évidemment c'est
une excellente chose
à partir de lundi à partir du 11 mai
nous allons rentrer dans une nouvelle
étape que nous voulons est le premier
ministre l'a rappelé le président de la
république l'a rappelé que nous voulons
plus prudent plus progressive mais où la
liberté de circulation va être rétablie
à partir du 11 mai les français pourront
sortir librement dans la rue sans
attestation néanmoins néanmoins nous
voulons éviter
évidemment que le virus ne se propage de
manière concomitante à cette liberté de
circulation restaurer pour des raisons
sanitaires
et c'est pour cela que le premier
ministre a annoncé qu'il y aurait une
règle d'interdiction des déplacements à
plus de 100 km du domicile dans un but
uniquement sanitaire et nous ne doutons
pas d'ailleurs que nos concitoyens
respecteront à nouveau cette règle comme
ils ont respecté les règles qui
s'appliquaient pendant le confinement
cette règle dès de l'interdiction des
déplacements de la 200 km du domicile
connaîtra effectivement des exceptions
vous avez rappelé les motifs qui sont
prévues des motifs familiaux ou des
motifs professionnels impérieux qui vont
être définis d'ailleurs le premier
ministre s'exprimera demain sur les
conditions de mise en oeuvre de cette
mesure et nous donnerons un certain
nombre de cas dans lesquels les
déplacements seront permis mais je veux
je m'en réfère à ce qu'a dit le premier
ministre est ce qu'on dit le président
de la république nous font une feront
surtout appel au civisme de nos
concitoyens et nous comptons beaucoup
sur la pédagogie qu'il faudra faire sur
l'effort d'information qu'il faudra
faire pour que ces règles soient
appliquées mais je ne doute pas que
quelques-uns quelques-unes des
exceptions que vous avez cité des
dérogations par dans que vous avez cités
comme par exemple venir soutenir un
parent malade un parent proche un parent
vulnérables je ne doute pas évidemment
que ce sera un motif de dérogation
permis mais encore une fois le premier
ministre déploie l'ensemble des mesures
applicables
demain
merci monsieur bériault merci monsieur
ministres effectivement je pense que sur
la question du motif familial impérieux
et puisse y avoir une confiance que nous
puissions avoir auprès des français
parce que c'est un sujet qui revient
très fréquemment les français sont
conscients des risques
on nous pouvons considérer qu'ils sont
capables de prendre les bonnes décisions
et qui sont capables également bien
évidemment de juger par eux mêmes ce qui
est bon pour eux votre bulle disait avec
raison que le plus grand soin d'un bon
gouvernement devrait être d'habitués peu
à peu les peuples à se passer de lui
merci merci
la parole est notre collègue mathieu
darnaud pour le groupe l'est républicain
vous avez la parole merci monsieur le
président monsieur le premier ministre
à l'heure où les parents d'élèves
s'inquiètent où les directeurs d'école
redoutent cette date du 11 mai et ses
nombreuses inconnues ou les mères
s'interroge sur leur capacité à répondre
à la lourdeur écrasante des protocoles
qui leur sont imposées il est temps que
le gouvernement rassure en envoyant des
signes clairs effort trop
d'interrogations demeurent sur la
question des moyens bien sûr je pense
ici aux masques au gel ou encore au
concours financier qui doivent soutenir
les communes et les intercommunalités
qui mettrait en oeuvre les activités
périscolaires que vous avez dénommé
sport santé civisme et culture à ce
propos nous souhaiterions une réponse
précise
quel protocole va s'appliquer pour ses
activités périscolaires un protocole
spécifique ou un protocole scolaire
enfin sur la problématique majeure de la
responsabilité dans le projet de loi
prorogeant l'état d'urgence le sénat a
souhaité offrir aux élus et aux
directeurs d'établissements l'assurance
qu'en appliquant des consignes dont ils
n'ont rien décidé il ne saurait être
poursuivis en cas de nouvelles
contaminations
il s'agit d'un préalable essentiel si
l'on veut garantir un climat de
confiance indispensable à cette rentrée
scolaire aussi question est claire
soutiendrez-vous cette disposition afin
que cette sortie du confinement souhaité
ne devienne pas une date redoutée je
vous remercie
mais si pour vous répondre la parole de
coglais mme lagarde
je suis le problème du corps de l'émoi
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur je vais répondre à
la dernière partie de votre question
parce que je crois qu'elle est centrale
à la question de la responsabilité
vous avez été mer gelée était aussi vous
savez comme moi que vous vous souvenez
comme moi à la fois de l'étendue des
responsabilités qui sont les nôtres
lorsque nous sommes élu maire je ne
pense pas d'ailleurs ni dans votre cas
ni dans le mien que cela nous ait jamais
empêché de prendre des décisions en
veillant dans toute la mesure du
possible à respecter la loi et en ne
cherchant jamais d'ailleurs à s'exonérer
des responsabilités qui étaient les
nôtres pense que de ce point de vue nous
sommes bien alignés vous avez raison de
dire que la perspective du déconfinement
interroge et parfois inquiète beaucoup
de nos concitoyens parce que le virus
fait peur parce que beaucoup d'inconnues
subsistent encore à la fois sur l'impact
médical sur la réalité de ce virus sur
ses modes de transmission mais aussi
parce que après une aussi longue période
de déconfinement reprendre une vie
normale même prudemment même
progressivement et forcément quelque
chose qui inquiète vous avez raison
d'indiquer que vous avez entendu nous
avons entendu nous sommes saisis de très
nombreuses interrogations formulées
parfois par les mères parfois par des
responsables associatifs parfois par des
chefs d'entreprises parfois par des
responsables administratifs qui
s'interroge sur les bonnes décisions à
prendre et qui parfois mais à titre
infiniment subsidiaire s'interrogent sur
la mise en cause de la responsabilité
qui pourrait être la leur quart jeudi 1
je ne dis pas que ça n'est pas important
mais je dis qu en général ceux qui ont
des décisions à prendre se pose d'abord
la question de savoir si la décision
qu'ils vont prendre est bonne
et ensuite de savoir si le cas échant ou
prévenir le leur reprocher je pense que
c'est l'expérience que vous avez là
aussi j'ai eu indiqué à cette tribune
mardi à l'occasion de la présentation du
plan de déconfinement que ces questions
et est sérieuse et qu'il fallait les
traiter sérieusement et que j'entendais
parfaitement que le parlement bien
entendu dans son pouvoir souverain
puisse essayer d'y apporter des
améliorations mais j'ai également
indiqué monsieur le sénateur je pense
que vous l'avez bien entendu que aussi
bien j'étais parfaitement favorable à ce
que on précise le droit existant qui est
déjà très protecteur grâce au sénat
d'ailleurs qu' il y a vingt ans a permis
à ce que la responsabilité des décideurs
comme on le dit parfois avec un peu de
facilité dans le langage soit beaucoup
mieux encadrer de façon à ce que leur
responsabilité ne soit pas trop
facilement trop systématiquement
recherchée dans des cas où il ne pouvait
pas être tenu responsable
je crois que ce dispositif est beau je
crois que s'agissant de la réouverture
des écoles c'est l'état qui prend la
responsabilité de les ré ouvrir c'est
l'état qui a fermé les écoles et c'est
l'état qui décidera de les ré ouvrir et
une responsabilité de l'état précisé que
ce soit s'agissant de la responsabilité
civile ou de la responsabilité pénale
le régime de responsabilité parce qu'il
faudrait inclure dans la loi des choses
qui sont déjà dans la jurisprudence
ou parce qu'il faudrait préciser qui
sait qu' on ne peut prendre des
décisions qu'en l'état actuel des
connaissances scientifiques par exemple
s'agissant d'une épidémie sans doute
mais atténuer la responsabilité atténuée
monsieur le sénateur la responsabilité
d'une catégorie de décideurs ou même de
tous les décideurs ne me semble pas une
bonne idée
je le dis comme je le pense en étant
conscient que
chez beaucoup de mères ma réponse peut
susciter des interrogations voire même
des oppositions
je pense monsieur le sénateur que si
nous donnions le sentiment ou plus
encore si effectivement nous atteignons
la responsabilité des décideurs nous ne
rentrions pas service à notre pays nous
ne redonne n'aurions pas confiance à nos
concitoyens et je me permets donc de
dire clairement que je ne m'inscris pas
du tout dans une logique d'atténuation
de la responsabilité
le parlement s'agissant du sénat s'est
exprimé la position du gouvernement a
été donné clairement l'assemblée
nationale va être saisie du texte tel
qu'il est issu du sénat
j'ai tendance à penser que le débat sera
intéressant moi je fais confiance à la
navette
je fais confiance à la discussion entre
les assemblées j'ai toujours fait
confiance à ce débat mais je vous ai dit
quelle était la position du gouvernement
jeudi le 900 la plus claire possible et
je pense monsieur le sénateur qu'ils
font songer y compris dans ces moments
d'angoissé il compris dans ces moments à
ce que pensent nos concitoyens de ce que
nous ferions
[Applaudissements]
monsieur d'arnaud lui seul oui monsieur
le premier ministre
certes c'est l'état qui prend la
responsabilité et vous ne pouvez pas
méconnaître que ce sont les maires qui
seront à la manoeuvre y compris
lorsqu'il s'agira dans le temps scolaire
de mettre en place des programmes qui
sont périscolaire et que l'agilité que
vous leur demandez n'est pas une chose
simple et je pense que si vous voulez
que ceux des confinement si vous voulez
que cette rentrée scolaire se passe de
la meilleure façon
alors il faut plus que jamais renouer le
lien de la confiance c'est cette
confiance qui permettra toutes les
formes de réussite jour merci merci la
parole des tca de notre collègue nadia
le goût pour le groupe de l'union
centriste avait la parole ma chère
collègue
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues les gens du voyage en tome
chaque année des mimes et une traversée
du pays en direction du littoral
atlantique ou du sud méditerranéen
cela concerne jusqu'à 25000 personnes
les maires et présidents de pci
compétent en matière d'accueil sont
extrêmement inquiets en cette période de
crise sanitaire
en effet les grands rassemblements sont
des pèlerinages de foi auquel il
pourrait être difficile de renoncer
monsieur le ministre ces moments de
population conduirait à d'inévitables
catastrophe que les élus de proximité
aurait à gérer en plus du reste nous
sommes très souvent dans cette période
de crise placé en situation d'urgence
c'est pourquoi je souhaite être rassurés
sur le fait que si risque de déplacement
ont été anticipées et que nous aurons
sur ce sujet une longueur d'avancé
je vous remercie pour vos réponses de la
parole et au secrétaire d'état auprès de
1001 térieur funès devait la parole
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs ou madame la
sénatrice
vous évoquez donc la situation des gens
du voyage je regardais mesures
sanitaires qui ont été pris je voudrais
d'abord vous rappeler que dans le cadre
du confinement
les gens du voyage respecte comme tous
les français les mesures qui ont été
prévues de confinement avec l'appui des
préfets et des responsables associatifs
des gens du voyage avec lesquels nous
sommes en discussion permanente dans le
cadre de la période qui s'ouvre à
compter de lundi
deux mesures vont concerner les gens du
voyage comme l'ensemble des français
c'est la mesure dont je parlais à
l'instant et pendant qu'on sénateur joël
guerriau mesure qui interdit les
déplacements au delà de 100 km du
domicile et puis l'autre mesure et vous
l'avez cité c'est celle qui interdit les
grands rassemblements jusqu'au 30 août
de cette année les grands rassemblements
plus de 5000 personnes ne seront pas
possibles pour la première mesure
l'interdiction de déplacement delà des
100 km nous verrons début juin quel est
l'état
l'évolution sanitaire dans notre pays
pour savoir si elle est maintenue ou pas
quant à la seconde nous avons d'ores et
déjà qu'elle durera jusqu'au 30 août et
que donc ces rassemblements ces grands
rassemblements ne pourront avoir lieu je
ne peux que vous le confirmer je pense
notamment rassemblement des saintes ou
au rassemblement de lourdes qui n'auront
pas lieu et je ne doute pas un seul
instant que nos concitoyens gens du
voyage respecteront cette interdiction
je puis vous dire que mes services sont
en contact avec les associations
représentatives des gens du voyage et
que nous discutons d'ores et déjà de ses
sujets et que nous ré ouvrir ont bien
évidemment un dialogue avec eux mais le
civisme dont ils ont fait preuve comme
tous les français pour le respect des
mesures de confinement nous laisse
augurer que il n'y aura pas il n'y aura
pas de non respect des règles que nous
allons fixer à compter du 11 mai je
puisse vous le garantir madame la
sénatrice de la même façon que je puis
vous garantir que nous continuons à
discuter avec les associations
représentatives des gens du voyage avec
lesquels les relations sont excellentes
puis vous assurer que nous allons
continuer à discuter pour la bonne
application de ces mesures de protection
sanitaire de nos concitoyens je remercie
monsieur le ministre parce que vous
aurez bien compris qu'il ne s'agissait
absolument pas de stigmatiser plutôt de
protéger les populations dans leur
propre intérêt
malgré tout quand on a été élu terrain
on sait très bien que ce ne sont pas les
arrêtés d'interdiction ni les guides de
bonnes pratiques qui servent mais que
quand les gens du voyage arrive
eh bien il faut aller en effet vous
l'avez dit discuter avec eux je dirais
les yeux dans les yeux et j'aurais même
dit dommage voilà donc c'est bien sur
cet aspect de la discussion je voulais
savoir au delà des grandes associations
nationales si les commission
départementale consultative des gens du
voyage avaient bien été également
sollicité si elles étaient
opérationnelles pour sécuriser la
situation
je voulais insister sur le ce risque
sanitaire et puis ce risque pour les
familles de se trouver en réelle
situation d'errance sur les routes
confrontés parfois même à l'hostilité
des populations sédentaires
il faut pas attendre jeu on a parlé des
maires qui sont en grande difficulté je
pense qu'il faut pas attendre que les
caravanes soit sur la route et le maire
au milieu de la route pour essayer de
gérer la situation
donc avec ces populations qui ont des
ces communautés qui présente des
spécificités
je vous remercie de me rassurer sur le
fait que le dialogue est bien toujours
présent il ya d'autres communautés
fragile ma collègue catherine fournier
nous a alertés par exemple sur une
problématique de migrants à calais
toutes ces populations rencontrent des
difficultés particulières dans cette
situation de crise sanitaire et il faut
absolument régler les choses par un
dialogue renforcé avec avec je remercie
la parole et à notre collègue julien
bargeton pour le groupe de la république
en marge de la parole monsieur le
président chers collègues ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'action et des
comptes publics
cette crise sanitaire inédite se double
d'une crise économique sans précédent
nous l'avons tous dit le parlement comme
le gouvernement surtout au chevet de
l'économie française
nous avons déjà voté de loi de finances
qui repose sur des outils principaux
nous les connaissons bien désormais
l'activité partielle qui concerne six
salariés sur dix le fonds de solidarité
pour les petites entreprises les prêts
garantis pour sauvegarder la trésorerie
et puis des prises de participation là
où dix grandes entreprises seraient
menacés ce sont les 4 piliers principaux
de cette action nous savons que
l'urgence commande d'agir parce que des
secteurs sont très menacées nous pensons
bien sûr à l'hôtellerie et à la
restauration au tourisme qui font
l'excellence française
nous pensons aussi aux grands noms aux
gens moins connus du secteur culturel
qui sont une âme d'autres pays et à cet
égard les annonces du président de la
république aujourd'hui vont dans le bon
sens et sont de nature à rassurer un
secteur qui est vraiment en péril à
paris dont je suis l'élu mais pas
seulement dans les villes la culture
permet de faire vivre ce qui est l'âme
de notre pays
le premier ministre dans son discours
ici a annoncé une mesure d'annulation
des décharges pour les entreprises de
moins de dix salariés vous même monsieur
ministre vous l'avez également évoqué
c'est une mesure attendue
c'est une mesure qui avait été demandé
et nous savons que réussir au maximum
l'urgence est nécessaire pour pouvoir
préparer la relance donc ma question est
de savoir si vous pouviez nous en dira
davantage quelles seraient les contours
d'une telle mesure
je vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole et communistes de l'action des
comptes publics monsieur norman avez la
parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur julien bargeton vous l'avez dit
le président de république d'une part
que le premier ministre devant votre
assemblée en début de semaine ont
annoncé des annulations de charges pour
les indépendants pour les commerces pour
les entreprises qui sont les plus
touchés par la crise notamment pour ceux
de ses commerces ses de ces entreprises
qui ont eu à connaître des fermetures de
la part du gouvernement qu'il soit dans
l'arrêté qu'a pris le gouvernement au
lendemain du 15 mars
ou alors du fait effectivement des
difficultés sanitaires extrêmement forte
que ces commerces aussi indépendants ont
eu à connaître
je voudrais d'abord préciser ici comme
j'ai pu le faire devant la commission
des affaires sociales à la demande du
président me le dire à quel point c'est
tout à fait originale dans l'histoire de
la protection sociale il n'y a jamais eu
d'annulation de charges pour des
secteurs y en a eu sur des zones
territoriales c'était le cas de saint
barth
saint martin au moment de dire mal
parfois le parlement décide de le faire
lui-même sur les ederer par exemple mais
jamais par secteur qu'allons-nous faire
une annulation totale de charges entre
le 15 mai et autres le 15 mars pardon et
le 15 juin pour l'ensemble du secteur
hôtellerie restauration tourisme arts et
spectacles culture sport pour toutes les
entreprises de moins de 250 salariés
et puis une annulation pour tout secteur
confondu pour toute entreprise de moins
de dix salariés qui ont dû fermer
pendant l'exemple des coiffeurs
évidemment que chacun connaît et sans
doute que tout le monde espère désormais
la réouverture c'est effectivement un
point très important
c'est après ce n'était pas une attaque
ad hominem monsieur le président en bas
âge
exactement
donc c'était tout à fait personnel aussi
comme réflexion je voulais dire à tort
bargeton que tous ces commerces qui ont
été obligés de fermer tous et
indépendant en plus évidemment de ce que
vous avez évoqué sur les indépendants je
devrais essayer dire qu'il ya six cent
soixante mille indépendant qui pour le
compte du mois d'avril ont demandé
l'aide c'est à dire au bout de six jours
plus de la moitié de ce qui a été
demandé au mois de mars on est bien la
demande est extrêmement forte
effectivement ces annulations de charge
seront complètes j'aurai l'occasion avec
mon collègue visa santé des solidarités
monsieur le président vous avez raison
j'aurai l'occasion de pouvoir préciser
dans les jours qui viennent avec les
représentants professionnels la
modalités exactes de ces annulations qui
n'ont jamais existé jusqu'à présent tenu
le site
la parole est à notre collègue françoise
laborde
merci rassemblement démocratique et
social européen vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président madame la
secrétaire d'état la filière
aéronautique concerne non seulement la
construction d'avions commerciaux mais
aussi la défense nationale et la
recherche spatiale
les industriels du secteur estiment que
la baisse du trafic aérien mondial va
impacter non seulement la solvabilité
des compagnies aériennes mais aussi
celle des avionneurs et des motoristes
c'est la chaîne d'approvisionnement
représentant 80% du coût d'un avion qui
sera le plus durement impacté les pertes
de compétences pourraient être
irréversibles pour les industriels de
l'aéronautique de l'espace et de la
défense
les observateurs s'accordent à dire qu'à
moyen ou long terme le marché repartira
l'industrie aéronautique rebondira il
convient donc de prendre en compte le
risque d'arriver d'acteurs étrangers qui
viendraient acheter les savoir faire et
compétences qu'il faut parfois dix ans à
acquérir sur certains postes
affaiblissant ainsi durablement les
avionneurs et les maths motoriste
français et européens
le plan de soutien du gouvernement aux
compagnies aériennes est accueillie
favorablement par les industriels de la
filière
mais encore faut-il alimenter
positivement le secteur en permettant de
renforcer les commandes tant en avions
commerciaux dont la flotte devra être
renouvelée avec des modèles plus
respectueux de l'environnement
quand commande publique pour la défense
nationale seuls ces investissements
permettront d'alimenter positivement
toute la chaîne de production qui compte
de nombreuses pme et eti stratégique
aujourd'hui fortement fragilisé
je sais madame que monsieur le ministre
de l'économie pardon et des finances
réunis cet après midi le comité
stratégique de la filière
c'est pourquoi afin de ne pas perdre ce
domaine d'excellence industrielle où
chacun dépend de l'autre je complète les
termes du courrier adressé par mon
collègue alain chatillon et cosignée par
les quinze parlementaires de la haute
garonne
madame la secrétaire d'état ne serait-il
pas important dans cette phase
intermédiaire que la france soutienne le
lancement de nouveaux programmes
ambitieux au niveau européen soutenu par
des avances remboursables
je vous remercie pour vous répondre la
parole et à la secrétaire d'état auprès
du ministre de l'économie et des
finances le même tenu en échec
merci beaucoup monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice laborde
je vous rejoins totalement dans
l'analyse que vous faites de l'état du
secteur de l'aéronautique qui est très
fortement impacté par cette crise du coc
vide
trois cent mille emplois 1200
entreprises d'exception nous sommes le
seul pays avec les états unis qui a la
capacité technologique à construire un
avion de a à z et nous tenons à confire
a conforté cette capacité alors
évidemment avec les avions commerciaux
qui sont cloués au sol aujourd'hui est
la situation de nombre de compagnies
aériennes
les perspectives de développement de
nouveaux programmes et de livraisons
d'avions sont particulièrement réduite
et c'est tout l'enjeu qui intéresse
aujourd'hui cette filière je veux dire
que nous avons accompagné le comité
stratégique de filière que ce que je les
ai réunis à plusieurs reprises depuis
deux mois maintenant
ainsi que l'ensemble des donneurs
d'ordre et sous traitants pour les
accompagner avec le ministère des
transports et avec le ministère des
armées
trois actions la première action
s'assurer qu'ils avaient bien enclenché
les mesures d'urgence notamment le
chômage partiel qui est la première
réponse pour conserver les compétences
extraordinaires dont nous disposons dans
l'aviation et vous avez raison de dire
qu'il faut parfois dix ans pour former
ses compétences deuxième action
s'assurer de la montée en capacité des
sites qui sont ouverts puisque eux n'ont
pas été confinés dans des conditions
sanitaires irréprochable ce qui suppose
à la fois d'accompagner le
l'approvisionnement en équipements de
protection et de s'assurer que les
protocoles sanitaires sont mis en place
et dans les meilleures conditions
non seulement dans les grands groupes ce
qui est évidemment le plus facile mais
également sur l'ensemble de la filière
dans les pme et les eti le troisième la
troisième action que nous livrons c'est
ce plan de soutien qui a été annoncé par
bruno le maire lundi et qui nous conduit
à réunir cet après midi le gifas le tube
currencies ensuite le comité stratégique
de filière pour faire le point sur la
situation et poser des solutions et un
plan de soutien
les contours de ce plan de soutien ne
reste à définir mais nous avons
clairement trois objectifs le premier
c'est d'accélérer la transition
écologique énergétique parce que c'est
un facteur différenciant et de
compétitivité
le deuxième c'est cette attention aux
sous traitants et donneurs d'ordre dans
ses relations et l'idée de mettre en
place un accompagnement des sous
traitants critiques notamment qui
pourrait être faire l'objet de prédation
depuis l'étranger enfin le troisième
objectif c'est de déployer massivement
usine du futur pour améliorer nos gars
je voulais conclure
merci la parole est notre collègue
cécile queyranne pour le groupe
communiste républicain citoyen et
écologique il avait la parole
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre le 13 avril dernier le
président de la république annoncé un
déconfinement et une réouverture
progressif des écoles le 11 mai cette
annonce a suscité de l'espoir
il restait quatre semaines pour
construire et réussir ce plan de
déconfinement cependant à quelques jours
de cette date c'est plutôt incertitudes
et colère parfois bien légitimes qui
s'expriment dans notre pays
monsieur le premier ministre les élus
locaux sont tous volontaires pour faire
vivre le service public dans leurs
territoires services publics garants de
l'égalité républicaine
mais ils ne sont pas volontaires pour
assumer les responsabilités qu'ils ne
sont pas les leurs et qui pour lesquels
ils n'ont pas les moyens
il refuse ainsi d'être demain les
coupables celles et ceux qui
inévitablement seront pointés du doigt
parce que votre décision de rouvrir les
écoles le 11 mai les invite
inévitablement à rouvrir les cantines
les transports scolaires dans quelques
semaines les internats et ils pourront
ils seront ainsi pointé du doigt parce
qu'ils seront responsables de la
propagation du virus dans leur
territoire
monsieur le premier ministre un
protocole sanitaire a été présentée
lundi
vous l'avez lu nous l'avons lu ce
protocole sanitaire et souvent
contradictoires mais surtout il est
inapplicable dans la plupart des écoles
de notre république
alors monsieur le premier ministre en
période de crise l'heure n'est pas à
faire comme on veut l'heure est assurée
par tous l'égalité républicaine
monsieur le premier ministre qu'entendez
vous faire d'ici au 11 mai pour assumer
vos responsabilités et donner les moyens
aux élus l'écho de les appliquer pour
vous répondre la parole et à madame le
garde des souris ni la justice
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président merci madame la sénatrice
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice kerman
vous évoquez d'une certaine manière le
désengagement de l'état qui renverrait
la responsabilité notamment celle de la
réouverture des écoles sur les mers vous
dites en même temps que dès lundi
dernier je crois mon collègue jean
michel blanquer a diffusé un texte qui
pose le cadre sanitaire et le cadre d'
accueil des élèves à partir des
recommandations du conseil scientifique
ce texte a fait l'objet d'une très large
concertation avec l'ensemble des
associations d'élus ce protocole
sanitaire fixe donc un cadre précis les
écoles n'ouvriront pas si elles ne sont
pas en mesure d'assurer suffisamment de
sécurité mais l'état ne se désengage pas
il a été clairement précisé que l'état
fait confiance aux acteurs qui sont les
plus proches des terrains et qu' il
accompagnera les communes vous demandez
en quelque sorte qu'ils soient dès lors
possible de d'inscrire dans un texte de
loi
une atténuation de la responsabilité
pénale des mères en raison des
responsabilités singulière qui devrait
apprendre durant cette période j'ai eu
l'occasion de m'exprimer devant vous
monsieur le premier ministre vient de le
redire à nouveau tels que le droit est
écrit aujourd'hui la responsabilité
pénale des décideurs
quels qu'ils soient d'ailleurs qu'il
s'agisse des maires des employeurs
publics privés
cette responsabilité pénale est
difficilement engage à bhl ou peut-être
en tout cas difficilement retenue
puisque il faut soit une faute délibérée
soit une faute caractérisée et c'est la
raison pour laquelle il me semble
difficile sauf à préciser la loi ce à
quoi je me suis montrée ouverte et ce à
quoi travaille d'ailleurs je crois
actuellement vos collègues de
l'assemblée nationale il me semble
difficile d'aller très au delà
d'ailleurs je me permets de faire
remarquer cela si nous décidions quelque
chose pour les élus locaux en raison du
principe d'égalité devant la loi pénale
c'est aussi pour l'ensemble des
décideurs qu'il faudrait le faire
les élus locaux les décideurs publics
mais aussi les chefs d'entreprise et les
décideurs privés
vous avez même la garde des sceaux je ne
dis jamais en même temps donc vous avez
certainement interprété mes propos je
crois que la question n'est pas là vous
parlez de droit pénal je vous parle de
ce qui s'exprime aujourd'hui chez
l'ensemble des îles dans l'ensemble des
élus locaux de notre pays
vous voulez assimilés l'ensemble des
décideurs locaux et bien oui assimilés
jusqu'au bout mais en tout état de cause
à partir du 11 mai c'est eux qui auront
la responsabilité d'expliquer aux
populations
pourquoi les écoles sont ouvertes ou
fermées et non vous la parole est
maintenant aux présidents vincent eblé
pour le groupe socialiste et républicain
vous avez la parole monsieur le
président merci monsieur le président ma
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre allait poser au nom de mes
collègues du groupe socialiste que
j'associe nous voici réunis aujourd'hui
pour une séance de questions au
gouvernement
mais les questions ne seront pas
l'apanage de la classe politique ce sont
les français qui s'en posent à ne plus
savoir à qui les adresser lundi vous
nous avez présenté monsieur le premier
ministre le plan de déconfinement c'est
peu dire que nous sommes restés sur
notre faim avec plus de questions que de
réponses priorité donnée à l'exigence de
santé ou à la reprise économique
sécurité sanitaire des enfants ou
libération des parents pour retourner
travailler
masques prioriser pour les soignants
mais inutile pour les citoyens qui
finalement devront obligatoirement
emporté dans les transports test massif
recommandé par le ms mais encore bien
peu usité pour préparer le déconfinement
distanciation physique quasi impossible
dans les transports aériens urbains
scolaire mais plage forêt interdite de
fréquentation monsieur le premier
ministre
les questions sont nombreuses elles sont
d'ailleurs le carburant nécessaire au
bon fonctionnement de notre démocratie
et du débat parlementaire
mais alors pourquoi certains exige-t-il
impossible unanimisme en qualifiant
d'irresponsables ceux qui expriment
toute critique ou opposition vous n'êtes
pas sans avoir observé à quel point le
sens des responsabilités a prévalu ici
lors de l'adoption des différents textes
qui nous ont été soumis loi d'urgence 2
loi de finances rectificative 2 nous
avons accordé beaucoup de moyens pour
agir contre cette pandémie désastreuse
mais la démocratie ne doit pas être une
victime supplémentaire du coc vide 19
janvier la question acceptez vous
monsieur le premier ministre de tenir
compte du rôle du parlement
majorité et opposition et d'agir demain
pour définir les conditions détaillées
du déconfinement sans forcément avoir
recours aux ordonnances qui le contourne
celle ci ayant déjà été largement
utilisée quand l'urgence exigée
on va répandre la parole et à monsieur
le premier ministre monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs
monsieur le président je suis à deux
doigts de vous répondre oui mais demeura
soir je vais pas le faire ce que vous
prendriez mal mais la vérité lorsque
vous me demandez monsieur le président
si le gouvernement est disponible pour
répondre aux questions disponibles pour
entendre ce que lui disent les
représentants de la nation réponse est
évidemment oui
et pour tout vous dire monsieur le
président je me permets de m'étonner que
vous puissiez en douter franchement nous
avons ici eu des débats sérieux je crois
digne qui n'était pas d'ailleurs
nécessairement consensuel mais après
tout les débats sont là pour ça vous
l'avez rappelé mais je ne crois pas que
quiconque puisse dire que le
gouvernement aurait refusé de répondre à
des questions ne se serait pas mis à la
disposition n'aurait pas respecté les
commissions du sénat
le sens du débat que vous ne soyez pas
d'accord avec toutes les réponses pour
l'entendre
ça c'est normal c'est la démocratie mais
ne laissons pas croire monsieur le
président à nos concitoyens que il y
aurait d'un côté ceux qui portent la
voix vivante de la démocratie et de
l'autre un gouvernement qui ne voudrait
pas l'entendre parce que ça ne
correspond pas à la vérité mais je crois
que vous le savez vous me posez avant de
poser la question de savoir si nous
étions disposés soucieux d'entendre ce
que le parlement a à dire est ce qu'il
souhaite faire prévaloir le parlement
dans son ensemble le sénat et
l'assemblée nationale
car ce sont les deux chambres qui font
la loi et aussi bien devons respecter le
sénat nous devons aussi respecter
l'assemblée nationale ne viendrait à
l'idée quiconque de penser que ça ne
devrait pas être le cas donc nous sommes
évidemment prêts à écouter entendre à
nourrir le débat essayer d'apporter les
positions qui ont été retenues par le
gouvernement et à les confronter le cas
échéant avec le souhait de la
représentation nationale au sens le plus
large
vous avez indiqué voudrais simplement
dire d'un mot parce que vous avez évoqué
beaucoup de sujets dans le début de
votre question le fait que vous n'auriez
pas
une réponse à la question de savoir si
la priorité c'était la santé ou la
reprise monsieur le président j'essaie
d'expliquer et je conçois que ce soit
tellement difficile à expliquer que je
suis sans doute insuffisamment clair
j'essaie d'expliquer depuis deux
semaines que le chemin de crête sur
lequel nous nous trouvons est un chemin
qui nous impose de tenir un équilibre
entre la sécurité sanitaire et la
reprise entre les deux c'est un
équilibre
c'est toujours difficile de maintenir un
équilibre mais vous voyez bien et vous
savez pertinemment que si nous donnons
la priorité à l'un en oubliant l'autre
nous risquons de très mauvaises
nouvelles de très mauvaises nouvelles
vous savez parfaitement monsieur le
président la catastrophe sociale qui
s'annonce et qui serait encore pire si
nous restions indéfiniment confiné vous
le savez vous la vivez dans votre
département enfin tout le monde la vie
tout le monde l'assentiment de la voit
arriver nous devons donc reprendre la
production
nous devons donc reprendre la vie
sociale nous devons donc reprendre
l'école parce que sinon c'est la
catastrophe
et nous savons aussi que si nous allons
trop vite par enthousiasme par
imprudence en privilégiant cette fois ci
la reprise sur la sécurité sanitaire
nous risquons dans ce cas là de très
mauvaises nouvelles sanitaires pourquoi
monsieur le président présentait les
choses comme si nous avions délibérément
choisi une priorité par rapport à
l'autre nous essayons justement et ce
n'est pas facile de garantir l'équilibré
entre ces deux principes et c'est un
chemin de crête c'est vrai avec 2 à pic
vertigineux et dans ce chemin de crête
je pense que nous gagnerions tous parce
que la nation est confrontée à une vraie
difficulté a essayé de
prendre et peut-être même monsieur le
président peut-être même d'expliquer la
nécessité de cet équilibre plutôt que de
nous accuser parfois d'aller trop d'un
côté parfois trop de l'autre on peut
évidemment discuter des déséquilibres
que nous essayons développer mais je
crois que nous avons tous intérêt
collectivement la nation intérêt à ce
qu'on explique la nécessité de préserver
cet équilibre mais je le crois bien plus
que simplement une présentation de l'un
ou de l'autre
oui j'entends vos dénégations monsieur
le premier ministre mais le terme d'
irresponsable gelé bien entendu
s'adressant à ceux qui ont exprimé
quelques réserves sur le plan de
déconfinement et par ailleurs je
n'entends pas dans votre réponse de
d'engagement relativement la procédure
des ordonnances qui s'explique dans
l'urgence mais qui à partir de
maintenant me paraît plus problématique
merci la parole est à notre collègue
jean françois rapin pour le groupe l'est
républicain
monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre pour le bicentenaire de
l'académie de médecine
il était arborer ce mot de marie curie
rien n'est à craindre tout est à
comprendre et j'avoue sans polémique
aucune qu'en cette période de pré
déconfinement j'ai parfois des
difficultés à comprendre toutes les
mesures et stratégies
ce qui forcément génère la crainte je
souhaiterais évoqué en particulier la
vie sur le littoral ainsi qu un point
précis sur le secteur agricole d'avis
sur le littoral du pas de calais sur les
littoraux de france est rythmée en ce
moment par de graves soucis économiques
mais je retiendrai trois sujets
premièrement le secteur de la pêche qui
même si des aides conjoncturelles sont
partiellement actes et craint de ne pas
pouvoir les voir arriver suffisamment
tôt pour encaisser le choc et s'inquiète
de son avenir
quant à l'aboutissement des mesures de
chômage partiel deuxièmement la question
migratoire
je soulève ici l'incompréhension des
élus locaux et des habitants de la ville
de calais malgré les moyens d'accueil
mis en place par l'état
le confinement n'est pas respecté par
les migrants il y a là un vrai sujet
d'incompréhension et de tension
troisièmement le sujet de la réouverture
des plages et des espaces de promenade
proches du rivage
l'apparition du clan
ce moment en couleurs inquiète et crée
de la confusion la confiance sur ce
sujet j'en suis convaincu
viendra de l'action qui sera mené entre
les préfets et les maires des sites
concernés des espaces immenses sur le
littoral ne me semble pas plus vecteur
de la contagion que les forêts ou les
parcs et jardins
vous savez comme moi que nous aurons du
mal aux beaux jours à maîtriser les
influences et je prône au plus vite la
concertation pour la mise en place d'un
dispositif local encadré qui permettra
une réouverture rapide
pouvez vous nous donner des perspectives
encourageantes sur ces sujets encore un
point d'incompréhension maintenant sur
la politique agricole
l'union européenne n'a t'elle pas mieux
à faire aujourd'hui que d'introduire un
accord de libre échange avec le mexique
dont le calendrier est une pure
maladresse quelles que soient les termes
de cet accord la crise sanitaire fait
prendre conscience que notre
souveraineté dans le domaine sanitaire
mais aussi alimentaire était essentiel
favorisantes de fait les circuits courts
pourquoi envoyer envoyé ce message
contradictoire en période troublée
quelle est la position du gouvernement à
ce sujet pour vous répondre
la parole est à monsieur lune aise
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur comprendrait que dans le temps
qui m'est imparti je ne pourrai répondre
à l'ensemble des questions sur
lesquelles vous intervenez le vous
interpeller le gouvernement
dans certaines touchent à la politique
agricole ou à la politique et que le
mythe je venais roman répondre à deux de
vos préoccupations concernant notamment
les migrants à calais vous dire que sur
ce sujet avec le ministre de l'intérieur
nous sommes en contact permanent
bien sûr avec la la maire de calais et
bien sûr avec le préfet des hauts de
france et le préfet du pas de calais oui
je vous confirme effectivement qu'un
certain nombre de migrants ne respectent
pas les mesures de confinement ce qui
nous a conduit à lancer et vous êtes
forcément informés de cette action
plusieurs opérations que nous appelons
des opérations de mise à l'abri qui sont
certes basée sur le principe du
volontariat mais qui nous on perd mais
permis pardon d'éloigner de mettre à
l'abri quelques centaines de migrants de
la côte du calaisis et nous poursuivons
dans le même temps des actions plus
volontariste plus
qui sont basées sur des actions
d'expulsion basée notamment sur des
ordonnances auquel nous accordons
concours de la force publique et nous
avons programmé un certain nombre
d'actions en ce sens
soyez certains que notre action sur le
sujet et déterminée et que je me rendrai
d'ailleurs personnellement à calais sans
doute dans les semaines qui viennent
pour faire le point de ses actions
concernant les plages monsieur le
sénateur je répondais tout à l'heure au
sénateur joël guerriau pour lui
expliquer la règle des 100 km la
prudence qui était la nôtre est
justement l'interdiction la non
accessibilité des plages à ce stade
jusqu'au 2 juin
elle repose justement sur la combinaison
de l'ensemble de ces règles l'idée qu'il
ya derrière tout ça et on comprend que
pour les personnes qui vivent à
proximité des plages
ce puisse être déchirant de ne pouvoir
s'y rendre mais cette la philosophie de
cette mesure repose sur le fait que nous
ne souhaitons pas inciter des personnes
des français qui verraient à plus de 100
kilomètres à se rendre sur ces lieux
attractifs que sont les littoraux
mais bien évidemment je veux redire que
la période qui s'ouvre du 11 mai au 2
juin n'est qu'une étape et que nous
aurons l'occasion de faire le point
au vu de l'évolution sanitaire de notre
pays à partir du 2 juin sur le maintien
ou non de cette mesure
voilà monsieur le sénateur merci
monsieur yvon reste monsieur rapin nous
aviez quelques secondes
oui je pensais que la règle permettait
de poser plusieurs questions et d'avoir
plusieurs réponses néanmoins je regrette
de ne pas avoir eu celle sur l'accord
avec le mexique parce que elle est
essentiel à mon sens aussi est
importante dans le contexte actuel crée
du stress et c'est pas un médecin que je
vais dire ça crée du stress sur le
stress ça n'est pas bon pour la
population bien la parole et à notre
collègue sabine van heghe pour le groupe
socialiste et républicain
il avait la parole ma chère collègue
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues
si les incertitudes sont encore
nombreuses ne savons que nous allons
devoir vivre avec le virus durant de
longs mois
un déconfinement progressive a cependant
commencé ce lundi prochain provoquant
chez les français beaucoup d'inquiétude
quant à la situation sanitaire mais
aussi économique et social qui pourrait
les impacter durablement le choc
économique va être très violent et plus
encore dans les secteurs d'activité qui
ne pourront pas reprendre le 11 mai
comme l'hôtellerie la restauration le
tourisme l'événementiel et d'autres
encore à période exceptionnelle mesures
économiques et sociales exceptionnelles
pour permettre la survie de milliers de
tpe pme qui ont besoin de visibilité
il est indispensable d'annuler leurs
charges et j'ai noté que vous alliez en
déterminer les concours ne nous y serons
attentifs 1 il ne s'agit pas de
générosité comme le gouvernement a pu le
dire mais de nécessité je veux aussi
insister sur les salariés actuellement
en chômage partiel
c'est plus de 11 millions de personnes
si la mise en activité partielle permet
d'amortir le choc
elle risque de durer au delà du 11 mai
pour les secteurs qui ne peuvent
redémarrer le groupe socialistes et
républicains souhaitent
dans tous ces cas le maintien du chômage
partiel dans sa forme actuelle sans
dégressivité et au delà du 1er juin des
effets pervers se profile pour les
droits à la retraite de certains
salariés notamment les moins rémunérés
d'entre eux dont l'indemnité de chômage
technique n'est pas soumise à
cotisations sociales et n'ouvre donc pas
de droit
cela concerne les salariés aux contrats
courts ou encore ceux qui font de petits
volumes horaires et qu'ils n'atteindront
pas les 600 heures de smic pour acquérir
quatre trimestres de cotisation
ma question est simple et attend une
réponse claire allez vous modifier le
dispositif actuel pour que la période de
chômage partiel soient prises en compte
et puissent donner lieu à des trimestres
cotisés pour tous les salariés
je vous remercie la parole est à madame
la ministre du travail madame que vous
avez la parole monsieur le président
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice sabine van heghe les
dispositions actuelles de l'activité
partielle permettent en effet pas de
générer des droits à la retraite de base
dans le régime général
jusqu'ici seul avait peu d'importance
puisque le chômage partiel
l'activité partielle était peu utilisé
pour des périodes courtes et donc ça ne
pénalisait pas les personnes concernées
en effet dans le régime de base un
trimestre et acquis dès lors que le
salarié justifie d'une rémunération au
moins égale à 150 fois le smic horaire
mais nous sommes vous l'avais dit dans
une situation tout à fait exceptionnelle
avec un chômage de partiel massif inédit
cna vous fait pour protéger les contrats
de travail de 12 millions de salariés et
qui donc aujourd'hui va durer ou dur
dans un certain nombre de secteurs de
façon assez prolonger puisque certains
secteurs ne peuvent pas ouvrir tout de
suite et que le chômage partiel dont va
continuer donc comment faire dans cette
période
évidemment notre but c'est qu'avec la
reprise économique ça concerne le moins
possible de salariés mais effectivement
si nous n'agissons pas certains verront
leurs droits à la retraite non
comptabilisées pendant la période de
chômage partiel c'est pourquoi nous
avons pris une décision je présenterai
demain en conseil des ministres une
disposition législative qui permettra
l'acquisition des droits à la retraite
de base pendant les parias d'activité
partielle cette mesure va permettre de
mieux protéger les salariés qui
subissent déjà les difficultés
engendrées par cette période mais qui
vont s'ils continuent dans le chômage
partiel subir un choc économique et
social important je crois que c'est
important pour protéger nos concitoyens
merci la parole est maintenant notre
collègue françoise gatel pour le groupe
de l'union centriste
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre je veux tout d'abord
saluer la qualité de l'engagement du
corps préfectoral aux côtés des élus
locaux car ensemble ils sont tous
devenus des inventeurs de possibles la
commission des lois et la délégation
collectivités suivent avec
intérêt la gestion de la crise dans les
territoires qu'avons nous appris nous
avons appris que cette crise était
protéiforme
elle était d'abord sanitaire mais elle
était aussi social et économique
elle est durable évolutif et parfois
imprévisibles qu'avons nous déduit que
la bataille à conduire doit être
collective mais ordonné qu avons nous
constaté des gestion territoriale
efficace quand elles réunissent autour
du préfet l'ensemble des acteurs locaux
dans un modèle de task force qui a pour
objectif de résoudre les questions c'est
ce que nous avons vu tout
particulièrement dans le morbihan en
ille et vilaine est encore ailleurs
mais nous avons aussi vu des pilotages
déficient parce qu'ils étaient
éparpillés ralenti parce qu'il y avait
plusieurs pilotes dans l'avion
à côté du préfet il ya en effet des
mines en soliste je veux parler de la rs
je veux parler des rectorats et parfois
des dr philippe ainsi l' agence
régionale de santé de bourgogne franche
comté vient d'informer le préfet par
circulaire de son intention de recruter
plus de 120 standardise pour assurer le
suivi et le logement des personnes qui
ont été touchées par des personnes
malades alors même que les élus les
préfets qui ont la solution n'ont pas du
tout été associé à cette initiative
pertinente mais mal mal engagée donc
cette gestion est bicéphale elle épuise
et elle affaiblit aussi ce matin j'ai
entendu beaucoup d'intérêt monsieur
castex parler pour le déconfinement
d'une gestion territorialisée du des
confirmands sous l'autorité unique du
préfet donc monsieur le ministre
j'attends avec impatience la réponse à
ma question confirmez-vous cette
excellente idée
je vous remercie ouais pont de la parole
et au secrétaire d'état auprès du
ministre de l'intérieur
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice d'abord en premier
lieu je voudrais vous remercier pour les
remerciements que vous adressez à
l'administration territoriale de l'état
au corps préfectoral bien sûr mais à
l'ensemble des services de l'état et je
ne résiste pas bien sûr à vous rappeler
que j'en ai moi même été membre pendant
plus de vingt ans de ma vie ça a été un
grand honneur
tout comme nous sommes avec les sauf
castaner très honoré et très flatté de
voir la façon dont nos services gère
cette crise totalement inédite sur
l'ensemble du territoire national
et je parle bien sûr des services des
préfectures des sous-préfectures et de
l'ensemble des services de l'état sur
les territoires qui donc le préfet donc
ses compétences propres qui sont aussi
des compétences d'animation
interministériel et qu'ils exercent dans
le cadre de cette crise je veux vous
rassurer madame la sénatrice totalement
certes le rectorat ses compétences
propres certes le ministère de l'action
à des comptes publics à des
représentations territorialisée qui ont
des compétences propres
certes les ars relève directement du
ministère de la santé ont des
compétences propres mais l'ensemble du
dispositif que nous avons mis en place
au plan national dans le cadre des
cellule interministérielle comme au plan
local il est bien articuler sous la
houlette sous l'animation des préfets et
d'ailleurs et d'ailleurs vous le
constaterez quand vous lirez évidemment
les circulaires du premier ministre sur
la façon dont nous allons gérer cette
nouvelle phase qui commence le 11 mai
bien évidemment qu'il existe des
instances de coordination d'articulation
entre les prérogatives qui sont celles
des préfets et les prérogatives qui sont
celles d'autres administrations d'autres
agences comme la rs et aussi bien dans
les actions que nous allons mener je
pense notamment au traçage je pense
notamment à l'hébergement des cas
contactez l'articulation qui va être
celle sur le terrain à celle du préfet
et du responsable des z et agressent
elle sera totale pleine et entière et je
veux vous rassurer sur un point s'il le
fallait encore tous les soirs le
ministre de l'intérieur en ma présence
réunit l'ensemble des préfets de région
et des préfets de zone et nous discutons
de ces sujets s'y joignent une fois par
semaine les directeurs des ars pour
justement que nous puissions coordonner
cette action est d'ailleurs le premier
ministre lui-même participe à certaines
de ses réunions et donne les impulsions
nécessaires
voilà mais encore une fois comme l'a dit
le premier
comme l'a dit également le président de
la république le moment venu nous tirons
bien évidemment tous les enseignements
de la façon dont les choses se sont
passées dont les administrations
fonctionner et s'il devait y avoir des
défaillances mais encore une fois ce
n'est pas le cas s'il devait y avoir des
ajustements apportés nous y réfléchir
nous y réfléchirons pardon soyez en
convaincus
la parole est à notre collègue christine
herzog pour la réunion de ministres
at-il déchets d'atr de figurant sur la
liste d' aucun gros vous avez la parole
merci monsieur le président cette
question s'adresse à monsieur le premier
ministre
l'annnonce de l'ouverture des écoles le
11 mai prochain suscite encore beaucoup
d'incompréhension et d'inquiétude chez
les mères l'état s'appuie très largement
sur les élus locaux pour mettre en
oeuvre ce dispositif censé être
opérationnel dans quelques jours ce
délai est d'autant plus difficile à
tenir qu'un grand nombre de questions
concrètes n'ont pas obtenu de réponse
les maires sont contraints à des choix
qui peuvent être lourds de conséquences
sur la santé de leurs populations
c'est aussi le cas des chefs
d'entreprise la question de la
responsabilité juridique doit donc être
rapidement clarifiée pourtant une fois
encore le gouvernement a refusé les
propositions faites par le sénat pour
répondre à l'inquiétude des maires il
faut maintenant remédier à cette
situation en faisant valider par la
préfecture les protocoles établis par
les maires cette protection juridique
est indispensable faut qu'il puisse agir
sans être accusé de faute qui n'auraient
pas commise ou qu'ils n'auront pas
commises
à la question de leur responsabilité
s'ajoute celle de la légitimité
en effet 86 % des communes ont élu au
premier tour des municipales un conseil
complet il est souhaitable que les
nouvelles équipes puissent être
installés rapidement afin de disposer de
la légitimité politique nécessaire le la
levée du confinement ayant lieu le 11
mai peut-on prévoir l'élection des
nouveaux maires auprès de cette date en
respectant bien entendu les règles
sanitaires indispensables
je vous demande donc monsieur le premier
ministre si d'une part vous envisagez
d'encadrer strictement la responsabilité
juridique
et mr et d'autre part si l'installation
des équipes municipales est envisageable
à partir du 11 mai pour vous répondre
la parole est à madame le garde des
sceaux ministre de la justice devait la
parole
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs madame la
sénatrice herzog
sur le second point de votre question le
premier ministre a eu l'occasion de vous
répondre lors du discours qu'il a
prononcé devant vous quant à
l'installation des exécutifs locaux je
reviendrai donc sur le premier point à
savoir la question de la responsabilité
des maires que nous avons déjà abordé
ici je dirais simplement trois choses
comme vous nous sommes tout à fait
sensible enfin le gouvernement comme les
parlementaires nous sommes tout à fait
sensible à l'inquiétude des élus locaux
comme également d'ailleurs de sel à
celle des chefs d'entreprise mais et
c'est le deuxième point je ne reviens
pas sur les règles de la responsabilité
pénale puisque c'est surtout cette
responsabilité là que vous évoquez sur
les règles de la responsabilité pénale
telle qu'elle existe t'elle d'ailleurs
qu'elle vous doivent beaucoup issus de
la loi fauchon est telle qu'elles sont
organisées elles sans cadre très
strictement la responsabilité des
décideurs
je pense toutefois comme vous aussi
qu'il est probablement nécessaire dans
un objectif de réassurance de clarifier
ses ce cadre juridique dans le contexte
très particulier d'une pandémie
pour autant je ne pense pas que la
solution qui a été adopté par le sénat
soit la solution la meilleure en
supprimant la possibilité d'engager la
responsabilité pénale de certains
décideurs pour une faute caractérisée
votre texte pourrait donner le sentiment
que ces décideurs cherchent à se
protéger et c'est bien d'ailleurs comme
ça qu'il a été lui je pense à une
tribune que j'ai lu hier soir de la part
d'un pénaliste renommée qui dit ceci le
dispositif voté par le sénat je le cite
serait une sorte de loi d'aministie par
avance qui n'a pas de précédent en droit
pénal français
je crois que pour notre démocratie se
serait délétère
suis certaine que vous partager cela
avec moi ce serait délétère de laisser
penser que nous souhaitons organiser une
impunité des décideurs dans une période
où l'exigence responsabilité est aussi
essentiel pour autant et je leur dis
devant vous je crois savoir que la
commission des lois de l'assemblée
nationale vient d'adopter un amendement
pourtant sur ces sujets là nous serons
bien sûr dans la navette dans le cadre
de la navette attentif à la manière dont
nous pourrons évoluer sur ces sujets
madame herzog
merci madame la ministre nous savons que
ces questions vont se poser à nouveau en
septembre
au delà des écoles les maires sont
sollicités pour l'ensemble des
confinement ils ont donc il est donc
urgent et nécessaire que ces problèmes
juridiques soient réglés rapidement afin
de les soutenir au mieux de leurs
fonctions sur merci beaucoup
avant de lever la séance je donne la
parole le président caennais re pour une
mise au point
oui simplement monsieur plus dans mes
chers collègues une simple mise au point
une correction sur le scrutin numéro 102
du 5 mai 2001 relatif à l'adoption de
l'article 6 du deuxième projet de loi
d'urgence que j'ai bien compris que
peut-être d'autres
dans quelque temps notre collègue
maurice antiste souhaitez voter contre
sur ce vote alors qu'il apparaît comme
ne participant pas au vote merci de bien
vouloir prendre en considération cette
petite modification
nous vous donnons acte de cette mise au
point qui sera publié au journal
officiel et figurera donc dans l'analyse
politique des scrutins concernés
monsieur le premier ministre nommé
messieurs du ministre merci nos
prochaines questions d'actualité au
gouvernement auront lieu le mercredi 13
mai 2020 je rappelle que une séance ray
programme et éventuellement le vendre
aux nuits et 8 mai le soir puis sous
réserve de leur dépôt les conclusions de
la commission mixte paritaire sur le
projet de loi prorogeant l'état
d'urgence sanitaire
comme je lé d'hier soir soutiendrait les
présidents de groupes politiques
informées de l'évolution météorologique
pour que nous puissions adapter nos
travaux dans les meilleures conditions
je n'ignore pas qu'elle se tourne deux
collègues ont beaucoup de kilomètres en
voiture pour venir jusqu'ici dans des
conditions de transport qui ne sont pas
faciles et il n'est pas mauvais que nos
concitoyens à mesure ce qu'est le
travail au quotidien de parlementaires
qui entendent que la démocratie vive
donc la séance est levée
voilà pour cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement qui se
termine donc avec cette mise au point de
gérard larcher qui a redit et bien le
travail des sénateurs notamment pour
venir se rendre au sénat et pour que le
travail parlementaire puisse s'effectuer
dans cette période très particulière du
confinement
cette question cette séance de questions
d'actualité au gouvernement a bien sûr
été l'occasion pour les sénateurs
d'interroger le gouvernement sur son
plan son plan de déconfinement qui doit
débuter à partir du 11 mai avec un
certain nombre de questions de questions
très concrètes autour des plages autour
de l'agriculture autour des gens du
voyage mais surtout avec une
préoccupation centrale qui est revenu à
travers plusieurs questions cette
question c'est celle de la
responsabilité des décideurs surtout la
responsabilité de maire on a bien senti
qu'au sein de l'hémicycle il y avait
deux positions d'une part et bien celle
des sénateurs qui ont adopté un
amendement modifier le projet de loi de
prorogation de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire pour modifier la loi pour
mieux sécuriser les maires et celle du
gouvernement qui est en désaccord avec
cette version mais qui néanmoins
entrouvre une porte on apprend en effet
qu'un amendement a été adopté en
commission aujourd'hui à l'assemblée
nationale écoutez tout à l'heure le
premier ministre edouard philippe qui
s'est exprimé à ce sujet je pense
monsieur le sénateur que si nous
donnions le sentiment ou plus encore si
effectivement nous atteignons
la responsabilité les décideurs nous ne
rentrions pas service à notre pays nous
ne redonne n'aurions pas confiance à nos
concitoyens et je me permets donc de
dire clairement que je ne m'inscris pas
du tout dans une logique d'atténuation
de la responsable sonar voilà pourrait
bien cette intervention d'edouard
philippe le premier ministre pour qui
est bien l' équilibre de la loi fauchon
adopté il ya une vingtaine d'années est
bon mais néanmoins il n'est pas
complètement fermée à la possibilité est
bien de préciser la loi même s'il ne
veut pas de ce régime d'atténuation
c'est ainsi qu'il a parlé du du régime
prévu par les sénateurs un régime
d'atténuation autour de cette question
de la responsabilité des élus et tout de
suite je suis avec la garde des sceaux
nicole belloubet justement et bien vous
avez répondu à une question sur ce sujet
c'est le sujet de la responsabilité des
élus
le gouvernement est finalement
favorables finalement à une réécriture
de la loi sur ce point il ya eu un amant
- qui a été adopté en commission à
l'assemblée que dit il exactement
il ya un moment où bonjour jordy a
effectivement un amendement qui vient à
l'instant d'être adopté en commission
des lois à l'assemblée
cet amendement vient préciser la
jurisprudence actuelle en matière de
responsabilité pénale
je rappelle que la responsabilité pénale
des élus ne peut être engagée que dans
des conditions extrêmement restrictives
prévu par la loi faute de la loi fauchon
qui a été d'ailleurs à laquelle on doit
beaucoup pour le sénat est donc ce sont
des conditions restrictives et là l'idée
serait si j'ai bien lu
l'amendement adopté par les députés mais
j'étais en séance serait d'ajouter un
élément qui prennent en compte l'état
des connaissances scientifiques
autrement dit ça permettrait dans le
cadre d'une crise comme celle du co vite
19 de tenir compte pour apprécier la
responsabilité des personnes des
décideurs de tenir compte de la réalité
des connaissances scientifiques et c'est
très important parce que si je peux me
permettre
un dernier mot cette responsabilité est
toujours appréciée au cas par cas en
tenant compte très précisément de la
situation dans laquelle se trouvait le
décideur donc si la loi dit que cette
situation doit être appréciée au regard
des connaissances scientifiques c'est un
point important pour le ch et c'est très
différent de ce qui a été adopté par le
sénat pour vous oui oui c'est très
différent puisque à la lecture de
l'amendement qui a été enfin du texte
qui a été adopté par le sénat il me
semble que l'on part sur un principe
d'irresponsabilité sur un principe de
rupture d'égalité dans le déclenchement
de la responsabilité puisque la fournée
parce que je les sénateurs un jeu wii
mais je je je peux le comprendre mais si
je pose sur ce texte un regard de
juristes je trouve qu'il ya une question
de rupture d'égalité qui me semble poser
problème entre les décideurs et vous
craignez aussi car ce sont les mots
d'edouard philippe que cela pose donc un
problème au niveau politique au niveau
de ce que je pense je pense qu'on va le
débat qui est en train de monter je suis
certaine que les sénateurs les
parlementaires partagent cette opinion
là il ne faut pas que les responsables
politiques donnent l'impression qu'ils
veulent se dédouaner de leurs
responsabilités je pense que nous
partageons cela est donc l'écriture doit
être ciselés et bien merci beaucoup
c'est vous qui avez loupé la garde des
sceaux qui était donc à mon micro à
l'instant merci beaucoup et justement
nous parlions de vous philippe bas le
président de la commission des lois est
à mon micro philippe bas vous étiez
également bien sûr rapporteur de ce
projet de loi de prorogation de l'état
d'urgence sanitaire et voulait toujours
puisque l'examen va se poursuivre encore
cette semaine votre réaction tout
d'abord au fait qu'il ya un amendement
qui a été adoptée à l'assemblée
nationale nicole belloubet l'a dit à
l'instant pour préciser
effectivement et bien l'état des
connaissances scientifiques ce que j'ai
cru comprendre
est ce que pour vous c'est quand même
une porte qui d'entre eux vers parce que
c'est satisfaisant à ce que non c'est
pas possible pour vous par rapport à ce
qu adopter le sénat rentrer dans les
procédures juridiques
je voudrais vous dire d'abord combien je
suis heureux que le sénat une très large
majorité est adopté des mesures qui vont
permettre aux français de sortir
progressivement de chez eux ne reprendre
le travail en ayant des garanties de
sécurité
le déconfinement c'est très difficile le
confinement c'est une mesure nationale
le déconfinement ce sont des dizaines de
milliers de décisions qui vont être
prises dans les ateliers dans les
bureaux dans les écoles dans les
administrations des dizaines de milliers
de personnes qui ont la responsabilité
des autres équipes vont devoir poser des
règles eh bien ils doivent savoir que
avec le respect des gestes-barrières
avec les tests de dépistage avec le
système pour remonter les filières de
contamination et mettre à l'écart les
personnes qui peuvent contaminer les
autres
il y a des garanties de sécurité il
appartiendra bien sûr aux pouvoirs
publics de mettre les moyens nécessaires
pour que cela fonctionne mais nous notre
travail c'est être posé les règles et
nous l'avons fait à cette question de la
responsabilité des élus est sûre ce qu'a
adoptées l'assemblée nationale est ce
qu'il peut y avoir un vrai point de
convergence sur ce point ou est-ce que
vous vous tenez à la rédaction du sénat
alors qu'il ya ce débat dont a parlé
edouard philippe où il dit attention à
ce que pensent nos concitoyens on a vu
certaines personnes notamment marine le
pen par exemple parlé d'auto aministie
préventive ce sont des mots qui sont
forts oui vous savez nous n'avons pas
l'habitude ici de nous inscrire dans des
polémiques politiciennes mais puisque je
vous disais tout à l'heure qu'il y à des
français qui sont des français de bonne
volonté qui vont devoir prendre des
dizaines de milliers de décisions chaque
jour pour le déconfinement il faut leur
dire pour qu'ils puissent le faire de
bon coeur en toute sécurité que ces
décisions ne le sont ne leur seront pas
mises à charge
à eux elles seront mises à charge de
ceux qui en réalité ont défini le
système et ont décidé des moyens à
mettre en oeuvre autrement dit je ne
veux pas moi d'un dispositif qui
permettrait de poursuivre les petits et
de protéger les puissants
je ne veux pas d'un dispositif qui
permettrait de clarifier la
responsabilité pénale du directeur
d'école du maire du responsable d'une
petite unité de production et qui en
profiterait pour créer une forme
d'exonération de responsabilité pour le
ministre pour le préfet pour le
directeur d' agences régionales de santé
qui eux fixant des règles pour vous
autrement dit quand un maire un chef
d'atelier un directeur d'école respecte
les obligations particulières de
prudence qui sont prévues par les lois
et les règlements qui ont été mises en
place pour lutter contre le vide 19
je ne vois pas pourquoi on lui ferait
courir un risque pénal
en revanche ce qui pose les règles il ne
s'agit pas de les mettre à l'abri
je crains malheureusement et c'est une
analyse juridique qui est partagé par
beaucoup de juristes que l'amendement
qui vient d'être adoptée à la commission
des lois de l'assemblée nationale ne
respectent pas ces conditions et nous
aurons l'occasion d'en discuter parce
que je suis convaincu que c'est un
volontairement parce que je n'imagine
pas que quiconque voudrait protéger ceux
qui sont les décideurs et non pas ceux
qui sont ceux qui vont appliquer sur le
terrain les mesures de déconfinement
très rapidement vous êtes optimiste pour
la commission mixte paritaire
je suis toujours optimiste parce que je
pense que le débat permet toujours de
faire progresser une vision partagée de
l'intérêt général et nous sommes dans
une période de la vie publique où chacun
doit prendre ses responsabilités et bien
merci beaucoup merci à iba d'avoir
répondu à mes questions je vais
accueillir à hervé morin le président de
la commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
hervé maurey vous qui portier une
proposition de loi qui a été transformé
en amendement et qui a donc été adoptée
dans la version du sénat et alors que
l'on apprend donc et bien que
l'assemblée nationale a elle même adopté
son propre amendement sur ce sujet en
commission des lois votre réaction
avec on vient d'avoir l'analyse de
philippe bas qui estime que et bien le
dispositif prévu par l'assemblée n'est
pas n'est pas adéquat pour l'instant si
vous ne serez pas étonné que mon analyse
soit proche de celle du président de la
commission des lois
effectivement l'amendement qui a été
adopté par la commission des lois de
l'assemblée nationale tels convient de
de le découvrir laisse à penser que
c'est une manière en s'abritant derrière
des sociétés savantes et les commissions
les comités d'experts une fois de plus
de pouvoirs exonérer les responsables
politiques au plus haut niveau et y
compris les ministres qui ont pris ces
dernières semaines et ces derniers mois
des mesures dont il pourrait avoir à
répondre dans les prochaines semaines et
les prochains mois
donc c'est évidemment une rédaction qui
ne nous convient pas du tout et on est
aux antipodes du discours que l'on
entend encore entendu aujourd'hui dans
l'hémicycle de la part du premier
ministre qui dit qu'il ne faudrait
surtout pas donner l'image que l'on veut
s'auto amnistier un amendement comme ça
c'est justement un amendement qui peut
laisser à penser qu'il y ait une volonté
du gouvernement de la majorité d'auto
amnistiés ou en tout cas de prémunir les
responsables politiques au plus haut
niveau de poursuites et nous c'est parce
qu'on veut au sénat ce qu'on veut c'est
protéger les mères et protéger toutes
celles et tous ceux qui doivent sur le
terrain au jour le jour prendre des
responsabilités des décisions difficiles
en ce moment vous renvoyer la balle dans
le camp du gouvernement sur sa critique
lorsqu'il dit et bien attention à la vie
des français avec les idées que les élus
et cherche à se dédouaner finalement
vous dites que la version qui est à à
laquelle le gouvernement est favorable
va bien plus loin dans ce sens bien sûr
puisque l'amendement qui a été voté au
sénat
exclu de manière très précise de toute
exonération éventuelle de responsabilité
les plus hauts responsables politiques
et notamment les ministres ce qui a été
voté à l'assemblée nationale ce n'est
pas ça du tout et donc effectivement il
y à il ya ce risque
alors attendons de voir ce qui est voté
ensuite dans l'hémicycle de l'assemblée
nationale hassan et que
le texte de la commission des lois de
l'assemblée nationale et puis essayons
surtout de voir comment en commission
mixte paritaire on arrive à retrouver
une version équilibrée une version
acceptable par les sénateurs qui
évidemment ne pourrait pas accepter ce
qui vient d'être adoptée à l'assemblée
nationale hervé maurey également
aujourd'hui vous avez fait une audition
celle de la ratp vous allez tout à
l'heure auditionné valérie pécresse
un mot sur cette question d'abord des
transports c'est une grande inconnue
c'est le plus grand des défis a
également estimé ce matin jean castex un
véritable casse tête notamment les
transports en commun c'est-à-dire un
secteur dans lequel ceux dont on parlait
juste avant la responsabilité d'un
certain nombre d'acteurs pourrait aussi
être engagée parce que l'on a bien
entendu ce matin en auditionnant là la
présidente de la ratp faire respecter
les gestes barrière dans les transports
en commun c'est elle même qui le dit ça
semble aujourd'hui
mission impossible et là aussi il
pourrait y avoir s'il ya pas un régime
protecteur mes responsabilités qui
toucherait les responsables de la ratp
ou d'autres sociétés qui sont amenés à
gérer des transports publics
donc effectivement à quelques jours du
déconfinement chacun se rend bien compte
que faire respecter les gestes barrière
dans les transports et notamment en ile
de france c'est extrêmement difficile
elle indiqué que pour pouvoir le faire
il faudrait que la ratp au lieu
d'accueillir 12 millions de voyageurs
par jour on n'accueille que deux ce
qu'est ce qui se passe s'il y a plus de
deux millions de voyageurs qui arrivent
de sur les quais qui arrivent dans les
gares fait de régulation des flux en
amont la présidente de la ratp a demandé
au gouvernement qui à ce stade ne lui a
pas encore répondu d'avoir des moyens
humains et notamment des des policiers à
sa demande selon les cas rares y entre
700 personnes et 2000 personnes pour
éviter qu'il y ait des attroupements qui
pose des problèmes en terme de sécurité
sanitaire et même en termes de sécurité
tout court
et ben j'imagine que ça lave a également
occupé et bien l'audition de valérie
pécresse tout à l'heure à tafer on va
auditionner dans quelques instants
valérie pécresse en sa qualité de
présidente d'ile-de-france mobilité bien
merci beaucoup et me reste une audition
d'ailleurs que vous allez pouvoir suivre
ici un quart d'heure vingt minutes en
direct sur notre antenne
maintenant on va prendre votre place
merci beaucoup hervé maurey patrick
kanner
le président du groupe socialiste au
sénat
tout d'abord et bien votre réaction
patrick kanner à ce que l'on apprend cet
amendement qui a été adopté par
l'assemblée nationale sur la question de
la responsabilité des élus pour
l'instant vos collègues notamment de
droite le lisse comme un amendement qui
dédouane les plus grands et qui
s'adresse aux plus petits décideurs
c'est ce que nous avons fait au sénat il
n'y a pas si longtemps que cela puisque
nous avons travaillé nuit et jour pour
adopté en première lecture ce projet de
loi ici nous ont fait un travail
équilibré bien sûr en sachant qu'il y a
des personnes sur exposé pendant le
déconfinement en tant qu'employeur
publics ou privés il n'y a pas que les
mères il ya aussi bien d'autres
employeurs directeur d'école peut être
aussi concernés par des procédures
judiciaires à son encontre
l'association iata d'associations
directeur je dirais de structures
culturelles par exemple bon très bien
donc nous ont pris une décision qui est
pour moi équilibrée que nous avons
soutenu même si nous mêmes en tant que
comme société nous avions une
composition plus restreinte au niveau
des élus dont tact là si j'ai lu ce que
l'assemblée nationale a priori voté en
commission à ce stade c'est l'idée de
dédouaner finalement de leurs
responsabilités ceux qui décident et qui
demande aux autres d'appliquer protéger
ceux qui te sont obligés d'appliquer des
décisions extrêmement complexe exemple
des directeurs d'école c'est une chose
mais des douanes et les ministres de
l'éducation nationale de ses
responsabilités j'ai été ministre et je
peux vous dire que quand on est ministre
on assume on ne saurait volonté pour une
maladresse pour vous de la part de la
majorité j'ai entendu monsieur philippe
bas avec son humour habituel dire c'est
sûrement une maladresse je crois que
manifestement la cour de justice de la
république
peut-être sera saisi dans la gestion de
la crise sanitaire que nous vivons
aujourd'hui pourra peut-être se
retrouver
il peut repousser dans le cadre cet
amendement non quand on est ministre on
assume
y compris devant ses pairs autant que de
besoin et en tout cas la commission
denquête au sénat sera toute la lumière
sur la manière dont cette crise a été
gérée et vous le savez sur la question
des masques ou détestent qu'on évoque
régulièrement justement également à ce
propos est ce que la saisine du conseil
constitutionnel sur ce texte pour vous
est toujours d'actualité tout à fait
nous allons bien sûr attendre le texte
qui sera sorti de l'assemblée nationale
après la cmp si elle est conclusive en
tout cas l'assemblée nationale aura le
dernier mot
et il est vrai que nous nous apprêtons
regard de ce que nous pouvons déjà à
savoir a déposé un recours devant le
conseil constitutionnel encore une fois
pour notamment protéger la question des
libertés individuelles et peut-être
aussi creuser cette question du fameux
stop qu'ovide qui ont dont on évoque la
sortie le 2 juin prochain alors que a
priori ça ne devait pas être le cas en
tout cas au sénat nous ont pris nos
responsabilités en supprimant une
ordonnance qui était prévue dans le
texte initial du gouvernement et qui
manifestement devait être le vecteur de
cette application est personne quelques
vides avec l'article 6 de ce projet de
loi une toute dernière question un peu
plus légères un mot sur l'image du jour
emmanuel m'apprend bras de chemise
canucks en moins en mode un petit peu
réunion de travail les décisions prises
pour le monde de la culture
cela fait déjà beaucoup réagir qu'est ce
que vous en avez pensé dans le président
de la république a l'habitude d'être en
bras de chemise
rappelez-vous les événements du grand
débat il était régulièrement en bras de
chemise c'est sa manière de communiquer
ce n'est pas la mienne mais voilà chacun
son style si vous me permettez
l'expression est un sourire chacun son
style merci beaucoup
patrick kanner d'avoir répondu à mes
questions et je vais à présent
accueillir claude malhuret
le président du groupe les indépendants
ici au sénat la même question un petit
peu qu à tout le monde mais tout de même
c'est l'actualité de la journée c'est
cet amendement qui a été donc adopté en
commission des lois à l'assemblée
nationale vous quelle lecture en faites
vous cet amendement qui porte sur la
question de la responsabilité des élus
bonjour tout d'abord
on voit bien que c'est un sujet
essentiel parce qu'on en parle beaucoup
les maires et aussi d'autres décideurs
de tracteurs locaux vont être placés
dans ce décor événements aux premières
loges au premier rang et par conséquent
affronteront des risques de toute nature
et ils devront décider et prendre des
décisions difficiles
ils y sont habitués c'est leur travail
toute l'année mais celles ci sont
peut-être encore plus difficile que
d'habitude
donc il est assez compréhensible et
c'est ce que le sénat a voulu faire de
leur donner une sécurité juridique de
l'ue qui puisse savoir exactement quelle
est leur responsabilité quelle n'est pas
leur responsabilité
le sénat a essayé de trouver une
solution l'assemblée nationale a trouvé
une autre solution
il y aura demain ou après demain une
commission mixte paritaire
je crois que est d'ailleurs le premier
ministre l'a rappelé le gouvernement a
une position l'assemblée une position le
sénat une position convergence eux dans
cette période où il faut évidemment
qu'on sort tous ensemble de ce bourbier
la sagesse commande de trouver une
solution de compromis en cmp l'essentiel
c'est d'arriver à cette sécurité
juridique que nous devons aux maires et
aux autres décideurs de ce pays dans
cette épreuve qui vont traverser et
difficile vous êtes montré d'ailleurs un
résolument pour le déconfinement à lundi
lors de ce débat qui a suivi la
déclaration du gouvernement sur le sujet
est ce que pour vous le gouvernement
aujourd'hui vous paraît suffisamment
claire suffisamment préparés puisque à
chaque jour on a un l'aude annonce alors
suffisamment clair c'est difficile parce
qu'il ya tellement d'incertitudes
moi je peux pas reprocher au
gouvernement de ne pas d'être pas clair
plus d'ailleurs je ne veux dire que
j'aurais plutôt tendance à le féliciter
d'avouer
ce dont on est sûr et ce dont on n'est
pas sûr c'est quand même assez courageux
de le faire même si ça peut entretenir
une incertitude donc on est dans une
situation extrême et russe inconnu peu
connus jusqu'à présent où les choses ne
peuvent pas être tout clair par
conséquent
je comprends qu'il puisse avoir des
hésitations et des incertitudes mais au
fur et à mesure il faudra les levées
quand on a affaire à une crise inédite
c'est comme ça que ça se passe je
comprends que je sois pas évident en
effet pas évident pour les français qui
doivent qui vont avoir le quai qui se
dit les français ont parfaitement
compris les gestes les distances et
assurons toutes les mesures préventives
ils ont compris aussi des risques et ce
qui veut dire que ils les attendent avec
impatience le déconfinement parce qu'ils
en ont assez de cette situation mais en
même temps il le voit il le redoute et
par conséquent il faut le plus
rapidement possible donner des réponses
claires mais je comble je comprends la
difficulté de ces réponses une toute
dernière question ce que vous avez eu
des nouvelles de jean luc mélenchon
claude malhuret jean luc mélenchon dont
vous avez parlé lundi comme du docteur
mélenchon de l'université de la havane
qui a fait un véritable buzz sur les
réseaux sociaux
oui dont je n'ai pas eu de nouvelles
mais vous savez on se parle visiblement
par un papa réseaux sociaux intervenus
au plus tôt les partisans de l'un ou
l'autre se parlent par réseau était à
poser directement non nous ne nous
sommes pas parlés pas de parole au delà
des réseaux sociaux merci beaucoup
claude malhuret d'avoir répondu à mes
questions le président du groupe les
indépendants je vais accueillir et de
catherine morin dessailly sénatrice us
et président de la commission de la
culture et de l'éducation
catherine morin desailly bonjour
première question bien sûr votre
réaction à ce plan à ces annonces disons
plutôt sur la culture d' emmanuel macron
avec notamment ces annonces qui concerne
les intermittents et puis la réouverture
d'un certain nombre de lieux à partir du
11 mai
le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que ces
annonces étaient attendues il était
temps d'ailleurs qu'elle ait lieu bien
entendu j'imagine qu'il aura d'autres
dans les jours à venir mais notre
commission de la culture au sénat qui
avait auditionné franck riester il ya
une douzaine de jours est en attente
d'un certain nombre de questions que
nous lui avions formulées quelle
anticipation qu'elle lisibilité pour le
secteur culturel quelle réponse apporter
à cette industrie
je parle d'industrie volontairement
c'est pas péjoratif au contraire c'est
très qualitatif ces ouï dire que le
secteur public et para connaissent est
un secteur économique extrêmement
puissant c'est 3,2 pour cent du pib
c'est beaucoup plus d'emplois que dans
le secteur automobile
et c'est toute une série de métiers
qu'on ne connaît pas à railler mais sur
les acteurs les artistes qui sont en
première ligne qui sont visibles mais
derrière tout ça ce sont des métiers des
techniciens des des éclairagistes d'où
ce monde qui accompagne la production
culturelle
donc il n'y avait pas vraiment de
réponse complète
même si un fonds d'urgence avait été
décrété et là on a un peu plus de
précisions notamment ce qui concerne la
question de l'intermittence oui est-ce
que vous jugez que cela arrive tout de
même tard même si bon il ya
effectivement cette annonce sur le
prolongement de droit des intermittents
jusqu'à ou 2021
disons qu'il est légitime d'analyser la
situation et les sujets sont tellement
nombreux dans le cadre de la réponse à
apporter à la crise qu'on peut
comprendre qu'il fallait un peu de
réflexion
mais malgré tout il faut rassurer et
pouvoir dire aussi à tous ces artistes à
tous ces créateurs tous et exigèrent de
ces administratif va compenser aussi à
le comme faisant partie prenante d'une
dynamique économique qui est porteuse
d'ailleurs de rayonnement et
d'attractivité pourquoi la france
est-elle un atout immense et je trouve
ça rire est un peu en décalage par
rapport aux annonces qu'on fait toutes
les grandes régions qui ont d'emblée
depuis un certain temps voter leurs
plans d'urgence et même parfois de
relance et son anticipation et que du
coup voilà on était un petit navire car
en pauvre de ce plan pour vous dans un
premier temps dans un premier temps oui
d'ailleurs
ce doit dire que les mesures qui ont été
annoncées et tant mieux nous les
soutenons fortement en faveur bien sûr
de tout le secteur économique en général
étaient les bienvenus mais il fallait
penser particulièrement à ce secteur qui
a des règles aussi un petit peu
particulière parce que la question de
l'intermittence est une réalité de
l'emploi dans le secteur culturel qui
n'existe pas ailleurs
les artistes sont pas employés d'une
structure et techniciens les et clarisse
ont paru de sa structure il accumule une
série de contrats voilà tout au long
d'une période dédiée qui ouvre après le
droit à l'assurance chômage
or tout cela vole en éclats quand il
n'ya plus de création et de diffusion
catherine morin desailly je le disais un
votre commission s'occupe également bien
sûr des questions d'éducation
l'éducation les écoles c'est quand même
le premier sujet avec la réouverture
alors à partir du 11 mai la plupart
plutôt quelques jours plus tard vous
quel inquiet dessus de 2 meur par
rapport à cette réouverture des écoles
je crois qu'elle voulait absolument
progressive concertée est assurée dans
des conditions sanitaires optimum c'est
la seule condition pour que les mères
qui sont quand même responsable de
l'ouverture de ses locaux où les grandes
collectivités mais on parlera plus tard
des collèges et des lycées et
l'assurance de pouvoir le faire dans des
bonnes conditions malgré tout oui ils
ont quelque peu peur que ce soit un peu
la défausse du gouvernement sur leur
propre entité municipale c'est la raison
pour laquelle il n'a pas échappée qui
sait au sénat à l'unanimité de nous
avons voté un dispositif spécial
dispositions particulières portant sur
la responsabilité des décideurs en
général des maires en particulier la
jambe le vient de voter le plan
commission dont on a les bras là pour
aussi ça sera exclusif particulier pour
cette période particulière et d'ailleurs
vous avez commencé par m'interroger sur
la culture dans le milieu culturel
on a besoin des mêmes assurances les
directeurs de musées et de structures
qui vont être possiblement réouverte à
partir du 11 mai et plus largement
j'espère par la suite se pose la même
question quelle est la part de
responsabilité
donc elle était essentielle cette
disposition ici j'espère qu'elle
perdurera dans le cadre de la navette
parlementaire et bien merci à beaucoup
catherine morin desailly d'avoir répondu
à mes questions et avant de rejoindre
une audition on va accueillir julien
bargeton sénateurs la république en
marche de paris julien bargeton merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous ou catherine
morin desailly je vous laisse vous vous
en allez devenir bargeton tout d'abord
votre réaction
avec à ce sujet de la responsabilité des
élus puisque le sénat avait adopté son
dispositif on apprend que l'assemblée
adopte elle aussi son dispositif du
moins cela bouge mais d'évidence les
deux chambres pour l'instant ne sont pas
encore d'accord moi je souhaite que
l'esprit qui a prévalu pendant les
débats sur la loi portant état d'urgence
sanitaire
prosper se poursuivent et que nous
puissions arriver à un accord sur ce
sujet de la responsabilité pas seulement
des mers d'ailleurs où des élus mais de
l'ensemble des personnes qui doivent
agir pendant cette crise sanitaire
nous verrons si un accord est possible
il faut à la fois protéger tous ceux qui
agissent mais aussi respecter les
principes de notre droit à nous de
trouver c'est possible à un nouvel
équilibre à voir si on peut le faire
certains de vos collègues ici au sénat
de droite de gauche jugent que le
dispositif qui a été adoptée à
l'assemblée il dédouane les plus grands
il dédouane les ministres est ce que
vous le lisez également comme cela je
crois qu'il ne faut pas faire de procès
d'intention de se lancer des anathèmes
ou de se donner sans cesse des leçons
moi je préfère finalement aidé que de
distribuer des bons ou des mauvais
points dans une telle crise il y à une
proposition du sénat désormais une
proposition de l'assemblée nationale le
travail va se poursuivre et nous verrons
si un accord une convergence est
possible ou non entre les deux chambres
si un état d'esprit qui le permet et
bien dans ce cas là il y aura une cmp
qui pourrait être conclusive
et sinon je le regretterai parce que je
pense que les différences peuvent
éventuellement être relevée encore une
fois il faut appliquer les principes
nous devons protéger tous ceux qui
agissent pendant la crise et nous devons
aussi respecter les grands principes de
notre droit
vous vous êtes réjouit un total air
notamment dans votre question de
des annonces des manuels macro sur la
culture ces annonces certains estiment
aussi qu elle arrive bien tard qu'est ce
que vous en pensez quoi vous savez quand
les choses arrivent tôt on dit ah ben
c'est pas vraiment une plan de relance
qui quand ça arrive plus tard on dit ça
arrive trop tard non il fallait
construire
il fallait il le ministre la culture à
consulter et écouter de très nombreux de
personnes dans le monde de la culture il
ya eu beaucoup de réunions de travail
pour le préparer ce plan est très
ambitieux le fait de donner une année
blanche tous les intermittents jusqu en
août 2021 c'était attendu c'est fait un
fonds pour aider aux tournages de films
et de séries la possibilité également
que la bpi interviennent dans le secteur
culturel
il ya eu beaucoup d'annoncés l'idée de
faire intervenir les artistes à l'école
ou encore d'inventer une nouvelle saison
ce programme est très riche
je crois qu'il est de nature à rassurer
les acteurs culturels ou même si le choc
ne nous vraiment ne nous faisons pas
d'illusions le choc sera fort pour le
secteur culturel
mais nous avons des annonces qui sont
très importantes très solide et qui
permettent d'amorcer la relance
culturelle amorcé la relance que tu
rates à sera le mot de la fin pour cette
série d'interviews merci beaucoup et pas
julien bargeton d'avoir répondu à mes
questions car tout de suite nous allons
prendre et bien à la direction d'une
audition auditions de valérie pécresse
la présidente de la région ile de france
qui est auditionné aujourd'hui par la
commission de l'aménagement du
territoire et du développement durable
présidée par le sénateur uc hervé maurey
respecter strictement ses rennes et dans
une région où il ya je crois 5 millions
de voyageurs transitent tous les jours
c'est évidemment extrêmement compliquée
et la question se pose de savoir comment
éviter un engorgement de transport kaki
rennes
comment éviter qu'il y ait un afflux de
voyageurs qui soit supérieur à la
capacité d'accueil de ces voyageurs avec
tous les problèmes
ça pose en termes de sécurité sanitaire
et même de sécurité à prendre de la ratp
nous indiqué ce matin qu'elle avait
comme vous je préfère la présidente
demandé à l'état des moyens humains
notamment en terme de forces de l'ordre
elle évoqué un chiffre
selon les scénarios se situerait entre
700 et 2010 policiers qu'il pourrait
qu'ils pourraient être nécessaires
bien sûr vous évoquerez cette question
et puis nous aimerions aussi que vous
puissiez évoquer le plan de défilement
que vous avez proposé avec une part
importante qu'y et de salariés qui
resterait en télétravail je crois que
c'était 100 % de salariés que vous
souhaitez voir rester en télétravail en
tout cas là la première semaine
vous avez également suggéré je crois que
les usagers disposent d'une attestation
de l'employeur bien montrer le caractère
obligatoire du fait qu'ils leur couple
ou transports publics pour aller
travailler
vous avez également fait des
propositions en matière de développement
du vélo s'il ne faudrait pas que là la
moindre capacité des transports publics
conduisent à ce qu'il y ait un recours
massif à la voiture individuelle et tous
les problèmes ça pourrait générer en
termes de l'engorgement et de pollution
et puis vous appelez je crois aussi de
vos voeux une remontée de l'offre de
transport qui dans un premier temps ne
sera que de 70 % de sa capacité actuelle
bien un sujet sur lequel nous aimerions
bien sûr également vous entendre c'est
la question des conséquences économiques
et financières de cette crise pour les
transports parisiens franciliens pardon
puisque vous subissez à la fois une
baisse des versements mobilité une
baisse des recettes voyageurs
je crois que vous avez estimé cette
perte de recettes à 1 milliard d'euros
vous avez je crois c é l'état pour lui
demander de compenser cette perte de
recettes nous indiquerait peut-être où
sont vos discussions avec l'état
de même vos relations avec la ratp
puisque je crois que vous avez demandé
une rénové négociation du contrat qui
vous lie à cette entreprise
voilà quelques points voulait évoquer
avant de laisser la parole didier
mandelli qui suit ces questions se
transporte au sein de notre commission
vous interrogera ensuite ainsi qu'un
certain nombre de mes collègues qui ont
d'ores et déjà demandé à la présidente
nous écoutons merci monsieur le
président mais vous avez déjà
pratiquement tout résumé donc je ne les
faire que confirmer ce que vous avez dit
c'est que évidemment ne mettons en ordre
de marche pour réfléchir le
déconfinement parce que nous estimons
mais j'imagine comme beaucoup au c'est
là que la question la crise économique
qui va suivre la crise sanitaire peut
impacter énormément le pays et tous les
foyers de france donc réussir le
déconfinement pour nous c'est une
priorité ça passe en île de france très
singulièrement par la résolution du
problème aigu de du goulet
d'étranglement des transports en commun
vous avez auditionné je crois jean
castex et catherine hiwar ce matin qui
vous ont expliqué qu'avec les règles
distanciation sociales qui sont
demandées par les autorités sanitaires
ne pourront pas transporter les 5
millions de personnes que nous
transportons habituellement la capacité
va être très réduite à l'instant t
jeudi à l'instant t parce que je vais y
revenir
ça veut dire que dans un bus qui
transporte aujourd'hui 60 ou 80
personnes on rentre transportera plus
que le vent dans un métro qui en
transporte 700 on n'en transporte aura
plus de 180 et dans un rire comme le rer
a qui transporte 2007 500 par jour on en
sera à les 800 donc évidemment à
l'instant t une capacité très réduite
c'est pour cela que nous avons proposé
plusieurs types de mesures pour essayer
de à la fois limitée l'arrivée d'un
transport des voyageurs mais aussi
accroître la capacité d'emport des
lignes alors toute une série de mesures
la première que nous avons demandé aux
entreprises et de maintenir le
télétravail au maximum et là je sors
d'une signature importante qui est un
préalable indispensable mais un une
vraie avancée la signature d'une
convention état région ile-de-france
mobilité collectivités employeurs medef
ces pme eu de paix partenaires sociaux
cfdt cftc sur le maintien du télétravail
en ile de france
il a été signé que jusqu à la fin de la
semaine du 18
jusqu'à la semaine et 18 nous serions un
stand au centre télétravail 8,25 à 90%
du 25 au 2 juin
nous savions à 80% de télétravail dans
ses trois premières semaines protocole
courau ses trois premières semaines nous
avons une charte signée par les
entreprises demandant effectivement à
chacun de rester et se maintient au
maximum du télétravail pour tous les
postes télé travaillable ensuite dans
cette charte il ya une deuxième
discussion qui me tient énormément à
coeur et dont j'espère que peut-être ce
ça peut être un héritage positif de la
crise que nous vivons actuellement
c'est un engagement ali s'est
massivement les heures de pointe le
lissage des heures de pointe c'est une
main de mes chevaux de bataille depuis
depuis plusieurs années et c'est l'idée
que aujourd'hui nous ne savons pas
remettre en cause nos habitudes
d'arrivée et de départ du travail que
celles ci sont essentiellement dictée
par des contingences sociales des
habitudes pas forcément par la nécessité
est donc là les d'entreprise cesse-t-on
se sont engagés dans un processus de
répartition égale et entre 6h30 et 7h30
8h30 à 9h30 et 10h30 pour l'arrivée de
leurs salariés et pour le départ entre
15h30 16h30 17h30 18h30 et 19h30 cet
étalement des points est quelque chose
de d'extrêmement profitable 6eme
transport est ce que ça veut dire qu'en
réalité en répartissant ainsi les
passagers
on pourrait transporter plus que le 1
million 5 ou 2 millions que vous a
annoncé catherine gloire ce matin parce
que ça voudrait dire qu on répartit les
voyageurs sur des plages horaires qui
sont beaucoup plus grande ce qui nous
permettrait d'avoir beaucoup plus de
capacités d'emport je le dis d'autant
plus que vous le savez bien les
transports en ile de france parce qu'ils
sont bombay effectivement ils sont
saturés effectivement mais une heure par
jour entre 7h30 et 8h30 et dès qu'on
passe ses pointes en réalité on se
trouve devant des transports qui
fonctionne plutôt bien voire même qui
peuvent être très faiblement rempli en
dehors des points à des heures très
creuse donc ça c'est un vrai premier pas
préalable qui est très important dans
cette charte il y à aussi et là aussi
c'est un engagement très fort des
entreprises le maintien d'une
attestation employeur
cette attestation employeur dirai aux
salariés à quelle heure il est attendu
dans l'entreprise et donc à quelle heure
il a le droit de prendre ses transports
en commun et cette attestation employeur
les employeurs ont accepté et les
partenaires sociaux ont signé rond
accepter qu'elles puissent être
contrôlés à l'entrée de l'égarer des
stations métro et faire l'objet d'un
chiffrage qui permettrait de ne pas
laisser entrer les personnes qui n'ont
pas l'autorisation de se dépasser allait
faire dit ça c'est très important parce
que si tous et sucé mis en place un
processus certes contraignant mais si ce
processus est mis en place nous pourrons
envisager de transporter beaucoup plus
de personnes en transport en commun
et comme vous l'avez très bien dit
monsieur le président nous avons
aujourd'hui deux préoccupations
la première c'est que l'île de france ne
se transforme pas en embouteillage géant
parce que les usagers par crainte de
reprendre les transports en commun et
bien finissent par se tourner tous vers
la voiture ou huit co l'île de france se
retrouve avec des lignes fermées ou des
grandes gares fermées
ce serait un paradoxe absolu d'avoir
maintenu et je me suis battu pour ça
d'avoir maintenu pendant toute la
période du confinement toutes les lignes
ratp sncf ouverte et d'avoir moins de
transport au moment où on les confine au
moment où on veut que l'activité
reprenne et au moment où on voudrait que
les salariés trouvent vraiment le chemin
de de l'emploi donc l'objectif ce serait
vraiment mérité ces fermetures de lignes
et de gare alors il reste encore un
certain nombre de questions qui doivent
être arbitrées par l'état qui ne l'ont
pas encore été
et qui devrait l'être dans l'exode les
jours qui viennent enfin en tout cas
très rapidement si on veut pouvoir avoir
un plan de transport qui a divisé dès
demain soir
c'est la question de cette attestation
employeur de sa validité et de son
contrôle
nous avons besoin de renforts vous
l'avez dit nous avons besoin de renforts
et filtré les entrées dans les gares et
dans les stations parce que évidemment
si on laisse rentrer trop nombre dans
les gares après une frappe plus question
de faire respecter la distanciation
sociale donc cette question du filtrage
pour cela les opérateurs m'avait demandé
la semaine dernière
5000 renforts de forces de sécurité
je vois que la négociation avec l'état
qui se poursuit fini par faire peut-être
converger les demandes vers des des
chiffres qui soit un tout petit peu plus
ou moins élevés ce qui veut dire que les
opérateurs vont avoir recours à des
sociétés de sécurité privées qui vont
pouvoir recruter eux-mêmes et que l'on
l'apport des opérateurs plus l'apport
des forces de l'ordre pourrait être un
tout petit peu plus faible que ses 5000
personnes qui avaient été initialement
annoncé comme indispensable par les
opérateurs
en tout cas moi ce que je souhaite c'est
que nous ayons ces renforts je pense que
c'est indispensable
il faut il ne faudrait pas non plus
qu'il y ait des risques de troubles à
l'ordre public dans les gares lundi
faute d'avoir ces forces d'apprendre
sécurité pour permettre les filtrages et
l'entrée dans les transports et la
fluidité de l'entrée dans les transports
alors vous m'avez posé beaucoup d'autres
question monsieur le président je crois
que m'avait aussi interrogé sur les
alternatives au transport en commun
alors sur les alternatives au transport
en commun
la région ile de france est en train de
travailler avec l'état et avec les
gestionnaires de voirie sur un plan de
centaines de kilomètres de pistes
cyclables supplémentaires
donc c'est aussi un plan très important
il fait beau c'est le printemps
le vélo est une alternative au transport
en commun pour beaucoup de nos
concitoyens notamment pour les petites
distances et donc eh bien cette offre
vélo va être va être considérablement
renforcé
j'ajoute qu'il ya une prime à l'achat de
vélos électriques de 500 euros qui a été
mise en
as parlé de france mobilité et qui
continuent d'être ouvert pour tous ceux
qui le voudraient et un service de
location vélos en longueur et
ile-de-france mobilité qui peut s'y mis
en place j'ai oublié de vous dire mais
vous l'aviez dit aussi vous même en
introduction que ile-de-france mobilité
c'était énormément mobilisés pour que
l'offre de transports reviennent à 100%
le plus rapidement possible les
opérateurs au début nous avait annoncé
qu'il ne voulait faire parce que 50 % le
11 mai nous avons obtenu que ce soit
plus près de 70% à la ratp et à la sncf
les chiffres sont encore à stabiliser en
tout cas 100 % sur les très grandes
lignes comme la une la 14 81% pour la
ligne 13 qui est évidemment très saturé
très congestionné et qui emmène des
personnes de quartier très populaire qui
n'occupe pas forcément des emplois
télétravail abl alors à leur boulot
alors alors alors emploi à leur travail
donc donc nous avons besoin que ces
lignes ne soit pas saturés qui est le
maximum d'offres est là aujourd'hui
la ratp la sncf nous disent que d'ici la
fin du mois de mai elle pourrait revenir
à 100 % de capacité d'emport ce qui
serait évidemment très important pour
nous le réseau optile de bus de grande
couronne lui nous annonçait être à 80 90
% des dés la rentrée alors par ailleurs
afin d'aider le dès qu'on finit alors
par ailleurs il ya évidemment un effort
considérable qui a été fait sur le
nettoyage et la désinfection des lignes
des rames et les bus je pense que
catherine bidoire vous en a déjà parlé
dix millions d'euros de plus investi
pareil de france mobilité pour pouvoir
nettoyer deux fois par jour les roms et
les élites enfin les rames et les gars
avec des procédés de nébulisation de
produits vie réussie pour désinfecter le
violoniste avec des protocoles qui sont
très importants 500 personnes dans des
brigades mobiles supplémentaires qui
vont venir nettoyer des transports pour
qu'ils soient évidemment plus sécurisant
or ceux qui vont les emprunter j'ajoute
une der dernier mot sur le covoiturage
le covoiturage est possible il est
possible les distances barrière d'après
l'autorité sanitaire sont respectées 6
alors je parle
hors du cercle familial qui évidemment
peut emprunter toutes là tous la même
voiture mais en dehors du cercle
familial les distances barrières sont
respectées ce qu' une personne s'assied
à l'arrière de la voiture en diagonale
par rapport aux conducteurs et donc le
conte le covoiturage peut reprendre et
c'est pour cela qu'il de france mobilité
mettra à nouveau des êtres très
puissante
ainsi patrice au développement du
covoiturage de façon à ce que évidemment
on puisse retrouver les mêmes nombres de
covoitureurs que pendant les grandes
grèves c'est à dire environ 20000
covoitureurs merci à ce que j'ai oublié
des choses mais chinoise et les autres
dossiers le milliards de manque à gagner
vos discussions avec l'état et la ratp
sur ce sujet alors effectivement à ce
stade je dis à ce stade parce que vous
voyez la reprise des transports va être
très progressive et le déconfinement va
être très contrôlés et crée très
ordonnée donc assez stable au moment où
je vous parle là l'addition du
confinement des deux mois de confinement
et près d'un milliard d'euros de manque
de recettes de france mobilité manque de
recettes moitié en versement transport
des entreprises qui ont fermé ou qui
n'ont pas eu d'activité et l'autre
moitié pour l'autre moitié pour le
manque de recettes
catherine guillouard voulait donner les
chiffres on est en dessous de 10 % de
fréquentation même plutôt au plus près
de 6 7 % de fréquentation aujourd'hui
donc évidemment les recettes voyageurs
ont complètement chuté alors vous vous
interrogiez sur qui su kyi qui subira
ses pertes tout les autorités
organisatrices de transport de france
ont écrit ensemble au premier ministre
pour lui dire qu'elle demandait une
garantie de recettes à l'état et qu'à
demander à l'état d'agir comme un filet
de sécurité pour nous prémunir
entre cette perte de recettes qui n'est
pas de notre fait qui n'est absolument
pas lié unis à une grève il ya un
dysfonctionnement ni un problème de
réseau qui est lié à une décision
nationale celle de comptes de confiner
le pays est de donc de perdre et redire
aux français de se déplacer donc on
estime qu'on est dans un état de
catastrophe sanitaire provoquée par une
décision nationale et donc il ya eu une
demande de maintien des recettes des
recettes de des autorités organisatrices
part il faut savoir les recettes des
autorités organisatrices vont
essentiellement au financement de
l'exploitation de la ratp de la sncf
donc tout ça est pas un jeu un peu à
somme nulle si les autorités
organisatrices non pas les recettes
elles ont du mal à payer
le contrat est ce qu'elles doivent aux
sociétés de transport et donc nécessité
de transport étant des sociétés elles
mêmes publics l'état se retrouve rage et
de renflouer les sociétés publiques donc
il ya un poudre est une vraie
négociation à voir sur qui porte le
poids de croix dans cette dans cette
affaire ile-de-france mobilité portant
évidemment la charge du remboursement du
passe navigo que nous avons décidé qui
est une décision politique que nous
avons décidé pour des raisons de justice
les détenteurs d'un pass navigo annuelle
sert d'un abonnement annuel n'ont pas pu
suspendre leur leur part parce que la
décision de confinement a été très
soudaine et que pour pour débrancher son
pass pour le mois suivant il faut se
rendre en gare
et évidemment il n'est pas question pour
nous d'un site et un million de
personnes après la décision de
confinement à se rendre en gare pour
désactiver son passe donc nous avons pas
pu désactiver les pages comme leur boîte
pu désactiver les passes nous avons
prélevé le montant du mois d'avril ce
qui était ce qui était injuste parce que
les voyageurs si vous avez pu aurait
évidemment désactiver leur face à
le président je vous ai perdu je ne vous
entend plus c'est moi qui ai pas
rebranchés mon micro excusez moi je dis
juste que j'avais donné la parole à
didier mandelli j'en ai dit si vous
m'entendez bien madame la présidente
bonjour je vous remercie vous n'êtes pas
l'engagement qu'ils étaient tout au long
de cette année semaines de crise et puis
surtout de votre engagement à bien
préparer les semaines et les mois qui
s'annoncent donc que encore bravo
pouvoir je pouvais plus mettre en oeuvre
j'ai trois questions à vous poser la
première porte sur un sujet qui est
évidemment d'actualité quotidienne il
s'agit des masques donc je sais que la
région a fêté comme enjeu le savoir vous
en étiez par rapport à ça et puis une
france mobilité s'est engagé à fournir à
chacun des stages et masque est ce que
cet engagement s'inscrit dans la durée à
quelle échéance et est ce que les
mesures complémentaires les opérateurs
ont indiqué également qu'il pourrait
éventuellement mettre à disposition des
équipements voilà est-ce que ce qu'on
s'inscrit dans la durée par rapport à
acea ces éléments la seconde question
porte sur les investissements et un
progrès très importants qui étaient
engagés en version dénommée trop
renouvellement de matériel et puis la
question parce que six en termes
d'investissements sur sur le grand paris
sur les travaux du grand paris express
est ce que dans dans le cadre de
nouveaux contrats
ces investissements seront sanctuarisés
est-ce que vous avez déjà une idée
précise sur sur ses engagements et puis
ma dernière question porte sur le
transport scolaire avec un peu plus
particulier sur vous avez évoqué les
questions de distanciation physique sur
le transport des enfants handicapés
notamment
est ce qu'il ya des dispositions
particulières qui sont qui sont d'ores
et déjà engagés pour la reprise du 11
mai les jours et les semaines sur moi je
vais m'arrêter là en complément des
questions vous a posé deux présidents et
puis je ne doute pas que mes collègues
auront
nombreuses questions à vous poser la
liste est d'ores et déjà passé à
s'imposant donc je m'arrête ici pour
pour les questions on a effectivement
plus d'une dizaine de sénateurs qui
souhaite vous interroger dans quoi tu
déjà vous laisser répondre aux questions
de monsieur demandé livre d'ordre sur la
politique de masques vous le savez la
réunion à acheter acheter 30 millions de
masques nous en avons déjà distribué 18
millions et nous avons commencé
évidemment en lien avec l'êta avant les
personnels prioritaires les soignants
les ehpad julie bensaïd rôles et
infirmiers libéraux les malades sur
ordonnance les collectivités toutes les
mairies les départements pour les aider
et puis petit à petit nous sommes venus
sur toutes les
toutes les personnes qui aujourd'hui
exercent des fonctions essentielles dans
le pays et nous avons beaucoup poussé
pour permettre l'équipement notamment
les opérateurs et des agents des
opérateurs de transport parce que nous
étions nous avons été vraiment sur la
corde raide à un moment en terme de
droit de retrait sur ses lignes sur ses
lignes de transport donc on a équipé
petit à petit y compris les taxes y
compris les ambulanciers donc on a on a
vraiment les vtc
donc on a vraiment été dans très loin
dans l'équipement alors maintenant nous
sommes arrivés au moment où nous
équipons les usagers des transports à
titre provisoire est pour comment dire
pour amorcer la honte parce que j'ai
demandé il ya plusieurs semaines au
gouvernement de rendre obligatoire le
port du masque dans les transports en
commun un moment du des confirmands et
pour moi ça me paraît être vraiment une
condition sinequanone de la confiance
retrouvée dans les transports en commun
il faut le dire aujourd'hui on est en
plein confinement alors il ya les
transports sont loin d'être saturé j'ai
moi même il ya encore dans le rer d
et on peut dire que la distanciation
sociale il est respecté comme elle ne
l'a jamais été
mais ce ne sera plus le cas le le 11
donc la question du port du masque
obligatoire pour moi était un préalable
indispensable
le gouvernement a accédé à ma demande a
accepté là aussi une verbalisation assez
sévères
à 135 euros du non port du masque donc
pour faire ça et bien il faut qu'on
fournisse des masques en tout cas dans
cette période où malheureusement on est
encore en pénurie pour se procurer des
masques et les usagers ne savent pas
encore comment son au curé donc comment
est ce qu'on va faire en faire trois
choses d'abord on a commencé à amorcer
la pompe avec les maires dans 160 gare
la semaine dernière dans 220 lundi nous
avons distribué plus d'un million six
cent mille masques et l'indien on en a
distribué on les a exprimés par par stop
de 10 de façon comme je vendredi et
fériés de façon à ce qu'on couvre y
compris lundis mardis 11 12
comme ça on pense qu'on a déjà amorcé la
pompe est con on a déjà beaucoup
d'usagers qui auront des masques pour
pour lundi mais il va falloir continuer
et donc j'ai dit à l'état qui lui même a
un stock de masques à distribuer lui
aussi pour le 11 12 que la région était
prête à apporter aussi un stock de
millions de masques pour aider à la
distribution les 11 et 12 dans les cars
toujours en lien avec l'ensemble des
maires d'ile-de-france qui sont
extrêmement mobilisés lors ma seule
crainte c'est que comme lundi il ya
aussi la réouverture des écoles dans
certaines communes c'est qu'il faut pas
que les équipes municipales se
démobilisent donc je vais je vais leur
les recontacter à travers le bois de
sacs des mères que nous avons mise en
place pour vérifier que tout le monde
est bien mobilisé aussi pour cette
distribution de lundi on se met aucune
distribution de masques jetables région
peut-être état aussi dans l'est dans les
gares au moins 220 car les mêmes que
ceux que nous avons ouverte lundi c'est
à dire les deux cent vingt plus grandes
gares par ailleurs ile-de-france
mobilité a commandé comme vous l'avez
dit 2 millions de masques tissu pour
chaque abonné navigo mensuel et annuel
nous nous en aurons huit cent mille déjà
en distribution le lundi prochain et
notre objectif est de travailler avec la
ratp la sncf ou identifier le maximum de
gare des petites garde des petites
stations dans lesquels on n'aura pas une
phénomène de foule mais dans lesquels du
coup au guichet
les agents de la ratp de la sncf
accepteront de données ce masque en
tissu à tous ceux qui se présenteraient
sur présentation de leur passe navigo
c'est un masque en tissu lavable 30 fois
et qui évidemment permet de pallier à la
pénurie de masques
troisième chose nous avons demandé à
toutes là tous les points de vente et
aux distributeurs qui sont dans le métro
et dans les gares de distribuer du gel
et les masques donc là aussi alors le
problème que nous avons que nous avons
découvert c'est que visiblement tous les
points de relais tous les points relais
ne vont pas forcément ouvrir donc on
n'est pas sûr qu'on aura tous les
magasins étaient ouverts dans le réseau
dès lundi donc on est en train de peser
pour essayer d'avoir le maximum de
points de vente pour le gel et pour les
masquer j'ajoute que nous aurons 300
distributeurs de gel hydro alcoolique
dans dans les différentes stations qui
seront mis en place par la ratp et la
sncf
j'ai pas parlé des bus je m'en excuse 30
gare routière aussi couverts par le
réseau peut-il pour la distribution des
masques tissu d'ile-de-france mobilité
ça c'est sur la question des masques
votre deuxième question était sûr on
investisse ments investissement alors là
je reprends mes notes si vous me le
permettez pour ne pas ne pas vous dire
de bêtises que je peux vous dire c'est
que tous les alors évidemment nous nous
nous attendons à ce que à part d'un
nombre d'investissements prioritaires
pour lui de franchement dignité et la
région soit décalé dans le temps à cause
du confinement et des retards qui ont
été pris dans les travaux dans les
travaux d'infrastructures mais aussi
malheureusement dans l'arrivée des
nouveaux matériels puisque vous le savez
les usines d'alstom les usines de
bombardier mais aussi les usines de bus
électriques qui devait nous nous
approvisionner en centaines de puce
électrique et au gaz que nous avions
commandé pour 2020 sont pas là arrêt
depuis deux mois et que remettre en
marche une usine ça prend un peu de
temps et on s'attend aussi à des
surcoûts sur tous ces chantiers et ses
commandes
puisque maintenant il y aura une
distanciation sociale il y aura des
contraintes sur les usines qui vont
faire qu'elles ne vont pas fonctionné de
la même manière et on s'attend aussi à
des surcoûts sur c'est donc des retards
et des surcoûts sur tous les chantiers
les travaux qu'il faudra ajouter à
l'addition de la perte de recettes que
je vous ai mentionné alors là dessus
aborder pour des temps des temps dès que
je vous disais tout pardon
donc nous nous avons nous allons nous
avons repris 100% des travaux qui sont
sous notre maîtrise d'ouvragé temps pour
cent les travaux qui sont sous maîtrise
d'ouvragé parle 80% des chantiers qui
semble sur notre maîtrise d'ouvragé ont
repris sur les opérations de transport
en général on était à 50 % de reprise en
début de semaine et on devrait
rapidement avoir tous les chantiers qui
reprennent après le confinement
avec évidemment des protocoles de
reprise des chantiers qui ont été
approuvés par le gouvernement et qui
correspondent aux mesures qui ont été
négociées par les partenaires sociaux
par ailleurs
donc c'est le protocole élaboré par lobé
pptp en lien avec l'état et tous les
acteurs du btp alors sur les transports
sur les la société du grand paris
alors sur les société du grand paris
évidemment c'est elle qui est
responsable de ces chantiers est à ce
stade
effectivement la question de la mise en
service des lignes la question des
surcoûts de chantier tout ça doit être
examiné dans le cadre des prochains
conseils d'administration et conseiller
surveillance de la sgp
la question de son modèle économique de
la sgp risque lui aussi peut se reposer
aux sénateurs au phare au parlement
assez assez rapidement parce que à cause
de la baisse de la productivité de nos
chantiers sur le transport scolaire sur
les transports scolaires
le premier ministre a évoqué dans son
discours il a dit les bus scolaires
circuleront à moitié vide avec
obligation de port du masque pour les
collégiens et les chauffeurs donc c'est
ce que nous sommes en train de préparer
normalement ça devrait se passer
correctement dès lors que les écoles
elles mêmes reprendront avec des demi
classe la seule chose que nous avons
fait savoir au maire et au département
et que nous n'envisagions pas de faire
des demi journées
est ce que faire des demi journées ça
impliquerait d'avoir une rotation de
transport scolaire à la mi journée ce
qui n'est juste pas possible en termes
de charge de travail président
on veut des journées pleines avec dès
2010 ce qui nous permettra avec notre
capacité d'emport de faire de tenter
tout le monde et peut-être
éventuellement de faire une rotation
supplémentaire si c'est nécessaire pour
les transports de personnes en situation
de handicap
évidemment nous nous prendrons les mêmes
précautions et nous travaillons en lien
avec les départements sur l'optimisation
du pam pour permettre à tous les enfants
en situation de handicap de pouvoir être
transporté bien merci merci beaucoup je
lui propose comme j'ai le dizaine de
demandes de parole de faire peut-être
deux groupes de cinq ou regrouper un
certain nombre de questions et j'ai
donné la parole à olivier jacquin merci
président mon journal le président si
votre disponibilité
plusieurs questions comment pérenniser
les décisions très positif qui doivent
être prises concernant l' usage du vélo
de voies spécifiques vélo une question
que l'on ne voit pas mettre en chantier
actuellement c'est une opportunité
donnée par la loi dans une plantation
d'immobilité elle est beaucoup plus loin
dans les voies réservées pour le
covoiturage avez vous une stratégie en
ce sens et n'est ce pas l'occasion de
lancer ces dispositifs de manière des
rites ablement ambitieuse petite
question de détails sur le remboursement
du passe navigo dont vous avez parlé qui
nécessite d'aller en gare
y at il possibilité de mettre en place
rapidement une procédure internet pour
rendre ces opérations faisable à
distance sur le choc économique l'eau
subit en ce moment dans le domaine des
transports
si je vous écoute tant au creux vous
laissez entendre que le modèle
économique de la société du grand paris
risque d'être remis en cause une
nouvelle fois les pertes de versements
mobilité sont extrêmement inquiétantes
ne faut-il pas freiné d'une manière
significative des investissements
l'inconnue actuelle du modèle économique
de transport en commun est véritablement
un certain et une autre question qui
fait suite à celle que j'ai posée ce
matin à madame guy noir sur les pertes
de recettes on contracte dsp avec ratp
peut laisser entendre qu'il y ait des
discussions sur le partage des pertes de
recettes entre l'autorité organisatrice
et le délégataire
comment voyez-vous des choses est la
dernière question c'est sur l'ouverture
à la concurrence dans le contexte ne
faudrait-il pas là au moins la
différence
je vous remercie merci je vais donner
merci monsieur le président madame la
présidente déjà beaucoup de questions
ont été posées j'en ai encore deux le 4
mai dernier la ministre borne à
mentionner la possibilité de fermer des
stations dans les transports publics
ces possibilités ne risque-t-elle pas au
contraire de rendre encore plus
difficile le respect de la distanciation
social en obligeant plus de personnes
arles se rendre dans la même station est
ma deuxième question c'est avez vous
prévu vous travaillez vous sur des
solutions innovantes pour éviter les
attroupements autour des bornes de
paiement et de recharge des titres de
transport merci merci monsieur puel va
madame dos idrac
merci monsieur le président bonjour
madame la présidente
oui effectivement beaucoup des questions
déjà été posées notamment sur la
distanciation qui est véritablement un
défi qui se présente à nous au delà du
maintien du télétravail sur lequel vous
êtes revenus effectivement on va avoir
des capacités différentes ces jours
prochains
si on va avoir environ 2 millions des 5
millions d'usagé habituel au moins être
accueillis avec des heures de pointe est
allé comme vous l'avez rappelé
effectivement dans vos propos liminaire
qui est une sans doute une mesure de bon
sens la présidente de la rs de la ratp
pardon que nous avons auditionné ce
matin nous a dit qu'il y aura une
augmentation de l'offre de transport
dans les
un jour et c'est évidemment souhaitable
même si le plan de transport n'est pas
encore connue toutefois est ce que ce
sera compatible au regard des exigences
sanitaires de nettoyage des rames avec
un flux de voyageurs en augmentation si
oui est-ce que les mesures sanitaires
que vous avez évoqué qu'elle a elle-même
évoqué seront selon vous suffisante et
surtout viable dans la durée avec ce
retour de flux des voyageurs et j'ai une
autre question à la présidente mais tout
d'abord je sais autour des masques
évidemment et je profite de cette
audition pour vous remercier vraiment
des actions que vous avez menées ces
derniers temps auprès des maires des
communes notamment des yvelines a donc
ce dimanche le secrétaire d'état aux
transports affirmé sûr que sur la
question de savoir si ce rôle c'est à
dire la distribution des masques
reviendrait aux opérateurs aux agents
des régions et que c'était toujours en
discussion puis sur l'inde il a précisé
que neuf millions de masse serait
distribuée dans l'ensemble des travaux
des transports en fait quelle sera la
répartition des rôles
à ce moment là notamment en termes de
protection des usagers et de
distribution de masques la coordination
présente elle selon vous des difficultés
notamment avec l'état et de façon en
fait plus générale attendez vous de la
part de l'état une aide dans le
renforcement de tous ses moyens
nécessaires que tout le monde évoque
mais pour lesquels on ne dit on ne sait
pas encore précisément qui fait quoi et
comment merci beaucoup madame la
présidente
merci même de ce monsieur foucher les i
allez-y vous m'entendez oui mais merci
me répétant à l'homme la présidente
j'ai apprécié votre intervention
concrète et déterminée est vrai qu
répartition des voyageurs sur des plages
horaires plus vaste une très bonne
solution a testé sur des employeurs
effectivement mais quand c'est dans un
premier temps sur tout mais qu'en est il
pour les gens qui veulent prendre des
transports en commun pour faire des
courses base donc pas forcément pour
travailler voilà c'était un premier
temps réservé
travailleur sur les ressorts qui est
vrai que vous avez raison il ya des
risques ce qui concerne notre public et
une bagarre donc il se cogne et c'est
absolument que le gouvernement mettre
les moyens
il est troisième point sur les pistes
cyclables est-ce que aurousseau bp
cyclable définitive ou provisoire ou
boyer il ya beaucoup de pistes cyclables
sur paris c'est très bien mais il ya des
embouteillages très fort et déjà depuis
depuis un symptôme de moi avec une
pollution très forte et si ces petites
sociétés qui vont être mises en place
reste on risque d'avoir une pollution
encore plus fort au niveau des véhicules
voilà mes questions de l'âme après des
notes merci d'abord merci beaucoup je
vais donner la parole à monsieur
chevrollier ensuite vous pourrez
répondre à la présente à ce premier bloc
de questions monsieur chevalier
oui merci monsieur le président madame
la présidente je salue votre engagement
elle présente deux régions pour réussir
ce déconfinement qui était effectivement
une priorité pour l'île de france mais
pour notre pays et chez lui aussi ce que
vous faites pour distribuer des masques
en y participant aux mêmes goûts même à
la distribution ce soit les masques
masque en tissu
moi je voulais connaître les relations
que vous avez actuellement avec la ville
de paris pour la gestion du
déconfinement quelle organisation
vous avez avec la ville de paris et
quelle est votre position sur la
décision de la municipalité parisienne
de thymine et encore les voies pour les
automobiles il peut être source de
nouveaux d'embouteillage assez
préjudiciable pour tout le monde et
notamment pour la qualité de l'air à
paris
deuxième question sur le coup vous avez
évoqué un milliard de recettes en moins
parmi les incidences est ce qu il peut y
en avoir justement au niveau des tarifs
des transports d'ile-de-france pour le
jour d'après et enfin sur le jour
d'après vous avez évoqué cette charte
avec les organisations patronales tout à
fait intéressant pour permettre
l'étalement
des horaires des travailleurs ile de
france qui tout à fait une piste tout à
fait intéressante pour la séquence du
déconfinement mais ce que vous envisagez
ensuite de pérenniser ce type de
dispositif pour qui à mon avis tout à
fait intéressant pour une meilleure
gestion des flux et meilleur éviter les
concentrations de populations et
permettre à la région capitale d'être
exemplaire des transports et permettent
aussi d'améliorer la qualité d'huile
moins de temps dans les transports avec
d'avoir ce dispositif qui soit pérennisé
dans le temps sur la mon avis une chose
à fait intéressante et profitable pour
tous merci merci beaucoup à la
présidence ou les biens répondant cette
série de questions quand j'ai essayé de
les regrouper je pense qu'ils avaient
une série de questions sur la question
du vélo par par monsieur jacques 1 mais
aussi par monsieur foucher et par
monsieur chevrier est donc là la
question du vélo et ça aujourd'hui faut
faire feu de tout bois on a besoin
d'alternatives aux transports en commun
le vélo aujourd'hui en ile-de-france et
400000 personnes on a on a eu des pics à
500000 personnes pendant les bandes
grève de décembre
il ya une envie de vélo en plus bon
c'est printemps il fait beau les
personnes ont été confinées elles ont
peut-être envie aussi un petit peu de se
défouler et puis il ya une défiance
vis-à-vis des transports en commun cette
période on a fait le choix vraiment du
vélo et notamment de travailler sur
quelque chose qu'on n'avait jamais
vraiment fait c'est à dire les coupes
une aubaine je pense aux portes de paris
je pense au franchissement de ville les
frontières les pistes cyclabes elle
était vraiment à l'intérieur d'une ville
et souvent il y avait pas beaucoup de
communication entre les villes donc la
région s'est beaucoup mobilisée avec
l'état et les gestionnaires de voirie
pour essayer de mettre en place un
circuit mais là je vous le dis ce sera
plusieurs centaines de kilomètres de
pistes cyclables provisoire alors moi ce
que je souhaite mère moi c'est que ce
soit réversible et que ce soit les
régions et à la fin
parce que l'équipement va pas être dans
une situation totalement normal à la
sortie de ce déconfinement et il faut il
va y avoir ré semblablement sait qui est
lui stable certains endroits dans
lesquels il y aura un conflit usages
entre le vélo
peut-être la voiture peut-être aussi les
bus parce que j'ai vu que certains
certains maires ont mis les pussycat
provisoire à la place des découvreurs de
bus donc ce qui peut se comprendre dans
une logique de oliva enfonçons sécurisé
les cyclistes et d'europe
là je pense qu'on est vraiment dans
l'expérimentation est une
expérimentation sur lequel il faut pas
freiner les bonnes volontés il faut au
contraire être être être très proactive
néanmoins moi je demande que le wh1
expérimente tout ça on les bat lui aussi
dans à l'été et qu'on regarde si c'est
ici qu'a doivent être pérennisés
si elles ont eu des effets néfastes sur
la circulation des bus ralentissement de
la vitesse commerciale par exemple bien
si l on crée comme l'a dit le sénateur
fouché des embouteillages à certains
endroits parce que la pollution des
voitures
on s'est écrit pl dans un embouteillage
que quand elle roule donc l'objectif
n'est pas de créer donc une congestion
un embouteillage géant aux portes de
paris par exemple
donc il faut qu'on ait une évaluation
cette expérimentation
tout ce qui est positif devra je pense
être gardés et ce sera pour le coup un
formidable élan condamnera à la pratique
du vélo en ile-de-france tout ce qui
pose problème devra être évaluée et
corriger ce qu'on peut imaginer par
exemple on est déjà en train de regarder
ça c'est que si par exemple la voix très
directe qui a été choisi en réalité ça
pose un problème de conflits d'usagé et
bien à ce moment là on peut très bien
imaginer que sur certaines portions
on y va on fasse des itinéraires bis et
que ce soit pas la voie la plus directe
qu'on mette en cyclables mais
durablement plutôt des petites rues de
compte pour de contournement de cette
voie directe
donc je pense qu'il faut qu'on soit tous
à la fois pragmatiques volontariste et
en même temps qu'on soit souple
voilà qu'on soit souple parce que je ne
voudrais pas que ont trait avec cette
formidable initiative et cette
formidable et ce formidable élan qui est
donné aux vêtements en ile de france
et j'allais dire des fractures et on
sait que malheureusement le virus est un
agrégateur des fractures territoriales
parce que ceux qui sont le plus loin ont
le plus de temps de transport bon avoir
peut-être dans cette aile de
déconfinement les plus en plus de
difficultés à se transporter et puis
ajoute pardon que la région a décidé de
financer à 60% le rer vélo qui est un
très beau programme de pénétrantes dans
paris qui double tous les grands axes de
rer et ce rer vélo et 1 est un
dispositif sur le long terme qui est
extrêmement puissante pour encourager le
vélo longue distance notamment le vélo
électrique
alors on se coupe nature âge monsieur
jacques 1 a demandé qui les voies
réservées pour le covoiturage seul est
mise en place
alors monsieur sénateurs je suis comme
vous
ces voix je les attends avec impatience
la loi maintenant à changer elle permet
de défaire mais en réalité ce dont on
s'est rendu compte avec avec l'état
c'est que le plus efficace pour mettre
des voies réservées pour les bus et le
covoiturage c'est utiliser la voie de
gauche par exemple sur les autoroutes la
voile de gauche parce que la voix de loi
qui est celle des échoppes des rentrées
les sorties haut ça suppose de dire que
les bandes d'arrêt d'urgence aujourd'hui
de rajouter une voix rajouter cette voie
ce serait rajoutée la bande d'arrêt
d'urgence et la fête en bois circulable
et ça aujourd'hui ce que nous dit la
lavaggi riffs c'est que aujourd'hui les
bandes d'arrêt d'urgence n'ont pas été
calibré pour un trafic normal et donc on
a un énorme travail à faire qui
pourraient être engagées dans le cadre
du prochain contrat de plan état région
pour essayer de rendre ces bandes
d'arrêt d'urgence des autoroutes
circulable et élargir d'une voie d'une
voix les autoroutes l'état avait proposé
que l'on fasse une boîte covoiturage en
enlevant une voix sur les autoroutes
ça me paraît pas raisonnable compte tenu
du degré congestion automobile de l'île
de france qui va sans doute être
renforcée malheureusement par la
défiance qu'auront les franciliens
vis-à-vis des transports en commun je
pense qu'il vaut mieux se mettre dans
une logique
une voie supplémentaire pour le
covoiturage plutôt que d'enlever une
voie à la circulation pour les
covoitureurs là encore ça risquerait de
provoquer des conflits d'usagé et vous
savez les tensions sont fortes sur ces
conflits en ile-de-france de la question
du choc économique et des modèles
économiques alors et je répondrai aussi
à la question de griller ou chevrollier
sur les tarifs pour moi il n'est pas
pensable que ce confinement
tu vas avoir des conséquences assez
dramatique sur le pouvoir d'achat de
certains grand nombre de ménages en
ile-de-france soit qu' il est fermé
leurs activités soit qu' ils soient au
chômage partiel au chômage donc pour moi
il n'est pas pensable que le
déconfinement se traduisent pour
récupérer ce milliards perdus par une
augmentation à due concurrence des
tarifs fois du passe navigo ça n'est pas
pensable
heureusement ile-de-france mobilité dans
une situation financière extrêmement
saine nous avons rétabli ses finances
après l'instauration du passe navigo
imite qui avait plongé l'île de france
dans dans un trou de 300 millions
d'euros non financées par an on a
rétabli les finances et aujourd'hui nous
sommes prêts à subir ce choc économique
qui est très fort maintenant il est
évident que ça aura un impact sur les
investissements qu'ils de france
possibilité pour affaires sauf si l'état
s'engage à compenser les pertes de
recettes
donc on a besoin de cette compensation
des pertes de recettes si on compte
beaucoup sur les parlementaires pour
nous y aider
on serait sollicité par toutes les
autorités organisatrices de transport
dans le même sens alors il vous nous
dites vous nous dites oui qu'il
supportera à la fin les pertes de
recettes bien ces sites c'est ce que je
vous disais et ile-de-france mobilité
n'ayant pas les recettes ne pourra pas
les donner à due concurrence aux
opérateurs qui eux mêmes n'ont pas été
en capacité pendant le confinement de
réaliser le service minimum puisque
l'offre de service qui a été proposé
pendant le confinement c'était seulement
30% de l'offre de transport habituel
alors que le seuil minimum vous savez
pour la ratp c'est un train sur deux
pour la sncf c'est au moins un train sur
trois donc je pense que le service
minimum n'a pas été respectée donc sur
toutes les lignes par les opérateurs non
plus par an donc on est tous en réalité
dans une situation de force majeure où
il y aura une négociation à voir avec
l'état pour savoir qui supportent quelle
charge à la fin à la fin du confinement
et la paix rhdp elle va vous avez très
justement dit que pour nous ce qu'il
fallait absolument éviter
c'était à la sortie du confinement de
fermer des grandes gares ou des lignes
nous ne voulons pas cette injustice pour
les voyageurs ne voulons pas que ceux
qui sont dans l'obligation se rendre au
travail se retrouve avec une situation
dégradée de transport c'est pour ça que
nous battons c'est pour ça que j'ai
appelé à des renforts considérables de
force sécurité forces de l'ordre forces
de sécurité supplémentaire payée par les
opérateurs
peut-être aussi police municipale
croix-rouge secouriste toutes les bonnes
volontés qui pourrait nous aider a
vraiment venir sécuriser l'entrée dans
les transports en commun pour respecter
les obligations de distanciation sociale
j'ajoute à ce stade que le gouvernement
a choisi vraiment l'option maximale
l'option maximale c'est la distanciation
sociales obligatoires
vous avez énormément de pays qui ont
fait le choix d'une distanciation social
recommandé ou d'une distanciation social
moindre ou même pas de distanciation
social du tout donc le gouvernement sur
les recommandations du conseil
scientifique a choisi lui l'obligation
l'obligation impérative de distanciation
sociale c'est ça qui fait que nous
sommes tous en train de nous retrousser
les manches ou prof chiffré est
rationnée l'arrivée de voyageurs dans
les transports en commun alors solutions
innovantes pour pour éviter les les fils
en gare absolument c'est ce que nous
sommes en train de faire puisque vous
savez que nous avons mis en place
logiquement ce qu'on a appelé le sms
ticketing la sms ticketing sait qu on
paye on n'achète plus sans ticket dans
l'eau russe depuis le début du
confinement on n'achète plus mon ticket
dans le bus on l'achète par sms par
téléphone ce qui permet de ne plus
échangées de mener dans les bus ça c'est
très important pour le pass navigo nous
avons deux nouvelles offres billettique
le pass navigo easy et le passe navigo
liberté plus le il dit c'est un porte
monnaie électronique sur lequel on peut
charger 7 et métro y compris sur
certains smartphones alors nous avons un
problème mais je crois que le
gouvernement a un peu le même avec apple
qui à ce stade n'a pas fait les
développements nécessaires pour qu'on
puisse on puisse utiliser apple pour
recharger les passes navigo les passes
navigo mais en revanche sur samsung et
sur tous les portables android et orange
je crois qu'aujourd'hui ne pouvons nous
pouvons avoir cette possibilité de
recharger les passes navigo ici nous
avons un nouvel un autre outil
billettique et le pass liberté plus se
passe-t-il verser plus c'est un système
de post paiement qui s'ajuste en
fonction de votre de votre consommation
de transport vous devez vous donnez vos
coordonnées bancaires et il vous est
prélevé le 15 du mois suivant en
fonction de votre consommation et donc
ça c'est un système de prélèvement qui
permet là encore de ne pas seulement pas
aller au guichet pas aller en gare et
d'avoir une relation très directe avec
les colis titre l' agence billettique
qui vous prélève en fonction de votre
consommation réelle de transport alors
ça un avantage aussi en termes de
pouvoir d'achat c'est qu'on achète on
fait pas des avances de trésorerie à
l'état en achetant des carnets de
tickets consommera dans six mois
consomment et il faut qu on a consommé à
moi mais après on paye c'est un c'est un
système qui a qu'il ya beaucoup
davantage et qui permet aussi ses
avantages supplémentaires combien donné
de faire la correspondance rer bus dans
paris ou métro bus dans paris pour un
seul
les outrances mille un bus dans pas
alors madame de cibles rock vous m'avez
demandé si nos procédures de nettoyage
serait compatible avec le retour de
l'affluence dans les transports en
commun écoutez nous allons mettre en
place une cellule de veille quotidienne
dans les transports en commun après
déconfinement pour surveiller de manière
très attentive
si nous nous apercevons qu'il ya une
saturation de telle ou telle ligne
notamment sur les lignes de bus où c'est
très très évolutive et évidemment les
lignes de bus des quartiers les plus
populaires sur toulon les plus peuplés
parce que les personnes qui les
empruntent ne télétravail pas sont dans
des emplois qui sont qui nécessitent du
présentiel
donc on va surveiller chaque ligne pour
voir l'évolution et donc on aura tous
l'histoire un point avec les opérateurs
sur chaque ligne
effectivement si on s'aperçoit que qu'il
ya beaucoup d' influence on ajustera
n'aurait processus de nettoyage à due
concurrence mais il faut ce nettoyage
est absolument indispensable donc il
faudra qu'on trouve une façon de
concilier poursuit les flux et le
nettoyage en bonne condition
on masque qui fait quoi alors là on est
encore en discussion avec l'état pour
savoir qui sera responsable de croire ce
que nous ne souhaitons pas il le
françois mitterrand et à la région c'est
que dans toutes les gares il puisse y
avoir une distribution sous une forme ou
sous une autre
c'est pour ça dans les petites gares et
petites stations l'idée ce serait plutôt
de privilégier la distribution du mas
tissu l'ile-de-france mobilité dans les
plu aux roses car j'ai les équipes des
maires qui sont en place qui ont fait un
super travail qui ont très bien couvert
le territoire donc j'ai proposé à l'état
qu'on renouvelle l'expérience
il faut savoir qu'aujourd'hui c'est très
difficile
l'ile-de-france mobilité a essayé de
trouver une entreprise qui s'engagent à
faire des distributions de masquer la
sortie des gares
voilà c'est très difficile les
protocoles de sécurité sont telles qu'on
n'a pas réussi à trouver le prestataire
extérieur privé pour faire ça donc on
est obligé de faire avec système d et de
recourir à j'allais dire toutes les
bonnes volontés
l'état de son côté
est en train de regarder avec les
préfets de département ce qu'il peut
mobiliser des équipes de secouristes ou
des équipes voilà parapublic pour pour
aider aussi à ces distributions mais ne
vous inquiétez pas ce sera en discussion
dans les jours qui viennent et toutes
les gares seront couvertes d'une manière
ou d'une autre les tailles nous nous
ferons le nécessaire reçues sur les
personnes qui vont faire les courses
sénateur fouché
moi ce que je propose c'est aussi une
forme d'auto discipline forme d'auto
discipline des voyageurs il faut donner
la priorité à ceux qui vont travailler
et c'est notre responsabilité collective
donc moi ce que je demande à tous les
franciliens c'est de ne pas utiliser les
transports en commun aux heures de
pointe pour aller faire leurs courses
tous ceux qui ont des courses affaires
peuvent les faire aux heures creuses
alors il ya évidemment des cas de figure
qui doivent être prévus
les élèves qui vont passer des examens
mais ils auront une vocation
les personnes qui vont voir le médecin
mais à ce moment là ils peuvent se
rédiger une attestation disant qu'ils
ont encore le médecin pense qu'il faudra
faire preuve de souplesse de
compréhension et de bon sens lorsqu'il y
aura un filtrage dans la gare et
certainement pas empêché se déplacer des
personnes qui auront besoin de se
déplacer ou des parents qui amènerait
leurs enfants à l'école par exemple
qu'il faudra faire preuve de souplesse
mais je pense néanmoins pour les
travailleurs l'attestation employeur est
un outil très puissant qui permet
d'étaler les flux je laisse des jeunes
voilà sur les relations avec la ville de
paris mais et elles sont elles sont
franches et cordiales comme toujours et
nous travaillons évidemment sur ce plan
vélo avec vraiment l'ambition de
développer l'offre vélo mais aussi et
c'est mon devoir en tant qu' autorité
organisatrice et aussi en tant que
présidente de région
l'obligation d'éviter les égoïsmes de
territoire il faut bien sûr que ya une
cohésion du plan de transport au niveau
régional et une cohérence aussi et que
tous les habitants de la région puissent
avoir la même liberté de déplacement
c'est un impératif que je me fixe
à la place qui est la mienne voilà je
crée alors sinon vous m'avez demandé
monsieur le sénateur si on pourrait
pérenniser ses expériences ses
expériences de télétravail et tissage
des heures de pointe alors je crois
vraiment que ça c'est un vrai travail de
flandre pour le sénat pour le parlement
mais aussi pour nous c'est peut-être
pour les chercheurs c'est comment est-ce
que le télétravail
comment est-ce que le virus va avoir un
impact sur l'organisation du travail
et j'imagine aussi que ça pourra jouer y
compris pour des régions limitrophes
vous êtes sénateur de la mayenne un
grand nombre d habitants dûment viennent
travailler en ile-de-france avec le
développement du télétravail
ils auront peut-être moins besoin de se
déplacer à l'avenir donc moi voilà nous
interrompons donc cette audition de
valérie pécresse la présidente de la
région ile de france qui s'exprime
encore actuellement devant les sénateurs
de la commission du développement
durable et de l'aménagement du
territoire commission présidée par le
sénateur uc hervé maurey l'occasion pour
la présidente de la région ile de france
et bien d'expliquer un petit peu tous
les défis face auxquels est bien la
région doit faire face avec l'épidémie 2
coronavirus premier défi on l'a entendu
bien sûr les flux de voyageurs les
transports c'est un défi qu'également
jean castex a pointé du doigt dont il a
parlé ce matin devant la commission de
l'aménagement du territoire le
coordonnateur de la stratégie nationale
de déconfinement vous pouvez toujours
voir et revoir toutes les auditions sur
notre site publicsenat.fr
très bonne soirée sur la chaîne
parlementaire
[Musique]